yes well I've been Shapiro has Gandhi
very good how's it going with you man
it's good well I love I love the new
digs I haven't been here since you
finished it over and I walked in I
thought to myself I've been doing my
business wrong I mean you got what three
employees yeah there's not that many
folks working on this yeah I mean so in
my offices we have like 80 and our
offices are not nearly this cool so I'm
gonna go back to my office and fire
everyone have your folks come in and
design because I mean it's either a lot
of people or I could have cars in my
office yeah but you wouldn't go down
this route you're you're more of a
conservative gentleman know myself
you're wearing a suit jacket you're your
own boss nobody tells you how to dress
and yet you dress like a grown-up yeah
well you know I won't pretend that
nobody tells me how to dress we have
people who tell me how to dress we have
people who do my hair do you have all
that stuff you have like fashion folks
yeah because I used to I mean if you
look at the old photos of me I have like
the Hitler hair I've got like the hair
that's the only thing about me the
tellurian was my old hair and I've got
the hair that kind of comes down over
the forehead and I still walk into the
office wearing basically an undershirt
every day because I'm incredibly lazy
when it comes to that stuff but we
should be able to yeah I mean that's
that's the prerogative of being the boss
maybe you'd be more relatable if you
showed up wearing like flip-flops and
t-shirt that kind of kills my brand oh
no does it like what is your brand
exactly very nice guy you're just
conservative that's the dirty little
secret though yeah about that but this
is one of the things that bothers me so
much about you being so misrepresented
when I read things about you there was a
the article that we were just talking
about the alt-right sage without the
rage they called you and you're not
alright in fact you were the leading
target of anti-semitic abuse for all of
2016 weren't you I'm going to the
anti-defamation league which is no la
mine so yeah I mean I'm not only am I
not all right I've spent the last four
years like legitimately battling the
alt-right talking about how evil I think
their ideology is how evil I think white
supremacy is I mean first of all like
people with yarmulke is typically not
the favorite
of the alright and then beyond that I
mean I think their ideology is
legitimately a devastatingly awful twist
on what Western civilization is supposed
to be was amazing as a review of my new
book and my new book has several
sections and they're dedicated to how
terrible the alt-right is and then the
interview they did with me doesn't talk
about all trite stuff at all but they
just assume I'm on the conservative
write that must mean that I am alright
it's like no you stupid labels they're
disingenuous people are labeling people
in a very simple manner to try to
categorize them as the enemy and instead
of just addressing these points like I
love watching your debates where you do
q and A's with college students and with
people in the audience because you can
see you agree with you or disagree with
you you have well formulated ideas this
isn't just some [ __ ] that you're
spouting out you've thought these things
through I've been doing this for
legitimately more than half my life I'm
35 and I started when I was 17 and I
started writing a syndicated column at
that point and when you're 17 you think
a lot of dumb stuff and then you get
older and you educate yourself and you
spend a lot of time reading and a lot of
time studying hopefully you have some
cogent arguments after 20 years of doing
anything I mean but it's the the
demonization is pretty astonishing me we
had ant on Andrew yang he's the only
Democratic candidate who has agreed to
go on the Sunday special that I do we
did a full hour on ubi it was perfectly
nice it was perfectly coherent and and
conciliatory and yet people will suggest
that everything I do is about destroying
people on the other side because of all
the Ben Shapiro destroy his videos
there's there are certain groups of
people where that's their stick they're
like they're goons right they just go
after people online for attention yes
this is a stick this is not you and this
is what bothers me so much and I know
that you've said some things in the past
like particularly about Arabs and like
when you were a younger man he said I
should have said that yeah that's
exactly right that's exactly some of
those things were taken out of context
like that one particular tweet which is
a bad tweet was a tweet that was part of
a tweet threat in which I was
specifically contrasting Israel and the
Hamas leadership and saying that the
Israeli government likes to build and
the Hamas leadership would prefer that
their citizens live in sewage and bomb
things but that was a bad tweet
obviously in my entire history on on
Muslim relations you
is one like I supported the ability of
Ilhan Omar to wear a hijab on the on the
floor I opposed president Trump's
originally proposed Muslim ban in the
last three weeks I've had on machine
awaaz I've had on contact med I had on
yesterday a reformed Muslim like these
are conversations that have to be had
but to take this is one of things that
bugs me so much I've tweeted I think a
hundred and forty thousand times I've
written millions of words I'm sure you
can find something I don't even remember
having written it is bad I have a
running list by the way I try to be
honest about this I'm one of the only
people I know who has I have a running
list it's called so here's a giant list
of all the dumb stuff I've ever done
right and I actually go through all the
see like you can look it up this is not
me saying this now I mean you can go and
look up all the things that I think I've
done wrong and I'll apologize for some
and I'll say somewhere dumb and I'll say
some I'm fine with and you're just
taking out of context but I mean that I
hope that's what honest people try to do
but this is the problem you're not
dealing with honest people when people
try to categorize you is alright or
they're trying to put you into this
category of internet goon they're the
and they quote tweet there's taking some
little tiny phrase you said seven years
ago and trying to say this is you this
is you now it's so that's such a
disingenuous thing to do I hate it and i
hate it across the aisle by the way i
was a defender of james gunn I thought
James Gunn should have been fired from
guardians of the galaxy jokes and even
if somebody tweeted something bad like
ten years ago
bringing it up now is not an attempt to
actually make the public space better
and you're not actually offended by that
thing the person tweeted ten years ago
that you didn't notice what it is that
you want to get rid of this person or
hurt this person so you're gonna bring
up something from ten years ago and then
you're gonna try and Club them into
submission with it because if you
actually ask them their opinion about it
they might have a more nuanced view on
what they said maybe they apologize
maybe they think I don't even remember
saying that right I mean I felt the same
way by the way I try to be consistent I
really do about about this stuff I said
the same thing about for example Ralph
Northam the the governor of Virginia who
was excoriated for having this terrible
racist photo on his yearbook page back
in medical school in 1987 and people
were saying well this is evidence he's
racist now I was like well no that's
evidence that he was doing a racist
thing then that's not evidence that he's
racist now you sort of have to look over
the broad core
of his career and he ended up doing what
everyone now does which is you just
don't apologize for anything you just
try to pass it off as and nothing the
public space is actually getting worse
because let's say that you did something
bad in the past there are a few human
responses to I did something I don't
like him past human response number one
is you know what I apologize that was
wrong these days that gets your face
stuff done right you say I apologize I
was wrong it means well why did you do
it in the first place because you're a
bad person
apologies are not accepted and then
number two is you brazen it out you do
the Trump you know what I never did
anything wrong ever
I've never perfect right and that and
then you get your defenders to come and
surround you and then nothing ever gets
cleansed or opportunity number three is
you do what Barack Obama did which is
you come out preemptively and you try to
remember all the bad stuff you do and
then you confess it in public so in
dreams from my father he says right well
you know when I was back in high school
did a little blow and if it's like oh
okay so you did cocaine when you was in
high school that's that's cool whereas
if it comes out during the campaign
right Stan he's boned right then he's
got he's got a real problem the problem
is that right now even if you
preemptively come out and say I did
something wrong like for example Liam
Neeson talking about years ago when he
had a racist thought that he didn't act
on when he had a racist thought this is
now we're gonna try and ruin your career
for something that you admit was bad
that you did 30 years ago we're gonna
try and ruin you over that if you
apologize for something that you did
thirty years ago which you would have
preferred just got forgotten because it
was embarrassing and stupid then we say
you're bad and so all you're left with
is like the most shameless people in the
world who are in the public space right
the incentive structure is to be deeply
shameless to just say yeah man I own
that and it was great when I said it or
I didn't say it at all
and you're just full of it I never said
that stuff who you gonna believe your
eyes or me and it makes it makes for a
really bad politics well it's just this
the culture of going after people for
things and and finding anything to
categorize them as someone who's a
viable target and this is what I've seen
thrust your way it's like there's
nothing wrong with being conservative
there's something wrong with wanting
everyone to think the way you think
though this is the difference like you
we what I like that you do is you debate
your points you state your positions you
have a
and what I don't like is when people try
to pretend that that philosophy is some
some somehow hateful or somehow
regressive or something like your that
you condemn people for their thoughts
you you just you don't this is what not
what I see with you I appreciate it and
I appreciate the accuracy exciting
that's true I mean I've come out against
virtually every Twitter ban including
people who have personally targeted me
I've come out against that I've come out
against virtually every what you know
let's talk about that because what do
you what are your thoughts about this
idea of deep platforming and you know
this is something that we were just
discussing before the podcast where the
CEO of YouTube and Kara Swisher
yeah from Rico I think Kara Swisher they
were talking about removing you from
YouTube and I thought it was the CEO of
YouTube it was actually Carol who said I
would if I could
yeah she's pissed because her son
apparently listens to that's kind of
funny she's being funny saying I could
but I thought it was the CEO of YouTube
mister she was trying to do the same
thing that they do with you or with Dave
Rubin or Jordan Peterson which is that
anybody who is sort of heterodox because
in that group I think I'm the only
registered Republican ever anybody who's
heterodox is now being exposed really
dogs meaning just thinks differently
from kind of the down the line
democratic party platform you're not
like down the line with Hillary yeah
like Sam Harris is a Democrat Sam Harris
is heterodox because he disagrees that
Islam is by necessity a religion of
peace for example right or he thinks
that we have to look at actual
statistics in order to make evidentiary
base points about discrimination and
disparity mm-hm and this makes him an
enemy of people like Ezra Klein at
voxcom
right the this sort of stuff they then
say that you are a feeder for white
supremacy right they they can't actually
get you on what you say yeah so it turns
into well you know some members of your
audience do things that that are really
bad there's like well dude I have like
millions of people who are members of my
audience have five million Facebook
followers I have two million on Twitter
and you're way bigger than I am I assume
that some of those people are gonna be
crazy yeah yeah the idea that your
response what YouTube tried to do you
know about the comment thing where the
YouTube was gonna try to make people
responsible for the comments in their
videos which what is a normal Jamie like
a normal
do that we get how many comments is a
good like 10,000 that's like a average
one how the [ __ ] am I supposed to have
subdued with this itchy trigger finger
standing by in front of a keyboard just
waiting for something offensive to pop
up and this was in response to something
that happened with them where there was
pedophiles who were watching videos of
children doing things and they were
commenting stuff in the you know like
the children's gymnastics and stuff like
that they're commenting and like
communicating with each other through
the comments and it was sort of
discovered that there was this
connection that they were doing this in
many many videos and YouTube rightly
panicked they're like holy [ __ ] we have
to stop this so the response I guess was
we just have to make people responsible
for their comments someone said oh yeah
good idea
you didn't think through it at all right
you know certain people that can't do
that it's totally insane and it's insane
and in virtually every respect and it's
it's funny how it's only applied kind of
by the media on one side of the aisle so
to take an example the Congressional
baseball shooting happens a couple of
years ago guy happens to be a Bernie fan
is that Bernie Sanders is fault right no
that is not Bernie Sanders is that went
away right literally people stopped
talking about in and that was shooting
of legislators like elected people one
nearly died and that kind of went away
we didn't talk about you know Bernie's
responsibility but there's a shooting in
Christchurch and it's Jordan Peterson's
fall and Jordan Peterson has no
relationship with the shooter whatsoever
it's my fault I have no relationship
with the shooter and denounce everything
that that piece of crap stands for and
suddenly is my it's it's really ugly and
it's gonna it will come home to roost I
mean here's what's gonna happen is
Facebook and YouTube are gonna fall prey
to their own standards because if their
standard is that you're responsible for
your followers or I'm responsible for my
followers or Jordan or anybody else is
responsible for all the people who view
their stuff okay then why isn't Facebook
responsible for all the people posting
on its platform if they are right at
Facebook becomes responsible for all the
people posting on its platform they'll
be bankrupt in a week they've got a
problem
they really do because they have to
decide whether they are a platform or
whether they are a do-gooder publication
yeah I run I run a publication daily
wire it's openly conservative we make no
bones about that and we are responsible
for the content that appears on our
platform and if we say something to
family Tory we will be sued if we say
something that
is false then we will be sued presumably
if you post something false on Facebook
Facebook doesn't get sued but now
Facebook has deemed itself the morality
police and they'll ban people they don't
like and Moe the decide what editorially
ought to be elevated and what ought not
to be elevated does that sound more like
the phone company to you or does that
sound more like my website where I
decide what gets published and what
doesn't right because Facebook's case
for exemption from these laws is well
we're like the phone company right when
you're on the phone with somebody if
that person says something criminal AT&T
isn't responsible for the person saying
something criminal or terrible it's just
the phone company right but Facebook
isn't doing that Facebook is jumping
into the middle of conversations and
then saying well we don't really like
this conversation so we're just gonna
kind of shut it down not because of
legal threat but because we just don't
like it so are they actually doing that
are you to say if you put a post up on
Facebook and they don't like the way you
worded things or described things where
they actually shut down your post what
will they do so they've done it in the
past to some conservative public
controversy because they're not
transparent at all right I can tell you
that the beginning of 2018 we lost about
35% of our traffic because Facebook
started cracking down on mostly
conservative sites they said that it was
kind of new sites generally but that's
not what the statistics showed they're
doing it more often with things that we
all sort of agree are bad right we all
agree white supremacy is bad white
nationalism is bad now they say they're
gonna censor that stuff but here's where
I'm uncomfortable I think that that
stuff is awful and evil and I those
people are the ones are the they're the
reason I have personal security but once
you get into the business of Facebook
gets to decide which speech is good and
which speech is bad they're an editor
yeah they're an editor even if I agree
with their assessment of what stuff is
good and what is bad I am not
comfortable with them in the driver's
seat there and if they are gonna be in
the driver's seat then they should be
held liable for all the stuff that's on
their platform I mean why is it the twit
Twitter same thing right why is it that
Louis Farrakhan is still on that
platform but Alex Jones is not like I
don't like Alex Jones his material or
I've been very very critical of Alex
Jones I didn't think he should get
banned from from Twitter unless he
actually violated the law unless he was
responsible for a violent threat and
let's use the fam'ly Tory or something
they're definitely going down this road
of being the moral arbitrators there
they're the ones who get to decide what
the conversations are and and that's an
insane responsibility the responsibility
of getting to dictate what shouldn't
should not be discussed and to have it
be a handful of people and have these
people almost almost exclusively live in
the Pacific that whole tech community I
mean it's all tech liberals who really
if you're around those people they live
in this really strange
uber wealthy bubble of super genius
spectrum people who are coders and super
capitalists and people that are raising
money all over the place and designing
technology and they have an ideology and
it's not necessarily a bad one just just
being honest and upfront about what it
is it's it's incredibly progressive
which is very unusual for big business
right for big business to be just openly
transparently progressive and pushing
social justice it's very unusual well I
think that there is a sort of
misunderstanding of when we say what big
business is what big business is so I
think that there's a wide variety of
owners of businesses and how they think
about politics obviously you know Gates
is a progressive guy Warren Buffett's a
progressive guy they are now he's
ruthless with Microsoft so I think that
there are a lot of people listen I think
that the vast majority are Crocker Berg
is ruthless with Facebook and he's
progressive I think Jack Dorsey is as
ruthless as the next guy when it comes
to profit I mean he's still got to be
answerable to his shareholders so I
think I think a lot of the progressivism
is sort of a way to excuse your own in
your own involvement in the capitalist
market Facebook took off don't be evil
that was their thing don't be evil they
decide to remove that yes Google right
Google yeah when Google did that I met
Google it's funny when you think
something but you're saying when they
did that it's like why would you ever
take off don't be evil like that but
here's my thing here's my thing I think
that if our tech companies were honest
they should take that stuff off like
stop pretending you're do Gooding you're
not do Gooding and providing a platform
and maybe the platform is the good right
in a capitalist economy the product that
you provide is the glue
I don't need additional good to come
from your product right if you want to
provide me a solid morning drink right
I don't need your politics along with
that I just need the drink well if I
want a social media company I don't give
two craps about what Mark Zuckerberg
thinks about politics dude hasn't
studied it I don't care at all what Jack
Dorsey who vacations in Malaysia and
gets bitten by a million mosquitoes
while meditating it has to say about the
nature of life like why do I care about
Jack Dorsey's political view he has
provided me a good the good is this
basic chatroom where I'm consuming news
how about that would just be enough but
it's not enough for a lot of these folks
it's it's the the kind of Huli from
Silicon Valley we're gonna pretend that
we're here to do good and it's not
enough just to acknowledge that may be
the thing that you provided is the good
like Bill Gates has done more good with
Microsoft and then he has done with any
of his charities he's even a lot of
money to charity but Microsoft has
provided legitimately hundreds of
thousands of jobs and created enormous
ly productive lines of business and made
enormous profit for a lot of people a
lot of people have stock in Microsoft as
a general thing he has done more good
doing that than giving tens of millions
of dollars to to various outside causes
so it feels like a lot of the
progressivism in in corporate halls and
in Silicon Valley is bifurcated mentally
it's like people have they're like
dolphins it's one side of the brain on
at a time here's my here's my
capitalists side where I go out and make
money and profit and then here's my
other side where I show people what a
great person I am by proclaiming that
I'm for Bernie Sanders while parking my
money offshore to make sure them there
it's shielded from that from the taxman
yeah well that's a good assessment what
I'm saying is that the the don't be evil
thing like one of the things that I
thought was a what if that was like a
legal decision was me being cynical that
they were pulled into some sort of an
office and said if we say don't be evil
and you take someone off the platform
you're accusing them of evil I mean then
we should slow that maybe I mean again
this this this self-assessment of you
are the moral police I find really
troubling it's so funny I'm the I'm the
supposed more or less right right I'm
the religious guy I'm the Orthodox Jew
right I talk about social standards and
how people should behave in their
personal life when it come
to government and when it comes to me
imposing my views on you I am away less
of a top-down tyrant than any of the
people in Silicon Valley I am NOT here
to tell you that you are not allowed to
be on a platform because we disagree
it's one thing if you're threatening
violence which is an actual violation of
law but this crap where people like me
because I believe in a social fabric
built on certain judeo-christian values
but I'm not forcing you to be part of
that and I'm not I don't think the
government should compel you to be a
part of that well I'm the tyrant but the
person who sits at the top of Twitter or
Facebook who is saying that they get to
police what you see and they're going to
nudge you in the right direction nudge
you in the right direction without your
consent without them even telling them
what you're doing right they're just
they're gonna push you a little bit
because they know better than you and
they can sort of massage you into better
views if we control your channels of
information this is something the Obama
administration was very fond of there's
a scholar named Cass Sunstein as a legal
scholar and he wrote a book called nudge
he was very famous it was it was used as
sort of a handbook during the Obama
administration and the idea was well if
we can just use non-forcible means sort
of nudge people in a particular
direction without them even knowing
they're being nudged then shouldn't we
do that and I think no you shouldn't you
shouldn't because transparency is the
only way I can tell what kind of
[ __ ] you're trying to tell me well
not just that like you you're closing
down even conversation if as soon as
you're trying to silence this other
voice if you if you believe one thing
and another person believes a different
thing you should probably talk about it
and the way the way that I know for sure
there's something wrong with your
argument is if what you're trying to do
is you're sneakily trying to silence
these voices and again as long as we're
not talking about threats of violence
and as long as we're not talking about
harassment or daxing right we're just
talking about conversation you're just
talking about people with differing
points of view if you want to silence
differing points of view I have to
wonder about your intent I have to
wonder about whether you're going into
this conversation with good faith I have
to wonder whether you've really
objectively assessed whether or not you
your argument does hold up against
scrutiny because this is also part of
the problem and when you're in an echo
chamber you often don't formulate these
arguments very well like when you
confront people about certain bias
beliefs that they have and you you have
an opposing belief if they're part of a
bubble like sometimes they might not
have even ever considered
some of the things you have to say and
I've seen that with some of your videos
yeah I mean it does happen all the time
and with sophisticated people I've spent
my entire life literally my entire life
in areas where everyone disagrees with
me yeah I grew up in LA I went to
Harvard Law School for three years I was
in Cambridge where everyone disagreed
with me and then I came back to LA so I
have never spent more than a week at a
time in a red state right whatever if
your conservative values moved in one
way or another of the I mean my personal
valleys probably haven't shifted very
much but my political values have
shifted libertarian hmm I mean so I used
to be a proponent of criminalization of
marijuana I'm no longer I've been in
favor for you a couple of things one was
just a general sense the government
sucks at everything mm-hmm and the more
I see the government try to crack down
on things the more prevalent it becomes
I mean people were dealing pot on my
sixth grade seventh grade playground in
public school obviously and then just a
general general perception not only the
government sucks at everything but that
you got to own your own actions and also
examining more of the evidence about the
impact of pot on people's lives and and
you know again there's you ruining your
own life through use of drugs and
there's drugs that legitimately ruin
other people's lives or there are drugs
that remove your ability to even reason
or think I think there are only two
reasons to criminalize drugs in any
fashion one is if there are drugs like
for example PCP that legitimately make
you violent and then you are going out
and committing acts of violence against
people then there's a case or if you're
talking about a where it legitimately
robs you of your capacity to reason if
it were heroin if you were able to
actually crack down on it successfully
but even there I'm not sure that the
proper government solution is
criminalization because we've
criminalized it and it's still
incredibly prevalent so I agree with you
I agree with on that and I agree with
you in terms of drugs being extremely
detrimental and the other part is that
there's comparable drugs that are legal
and comparable drugs meaning not even
really comparable drugs that are far
more devastating like alcohol like you
could just go to any grocery store and
buy a jug of whiskey and kill yourself
with it yeah it's not difficult industry
having
books already that prevent externalities
if you drive high it's the same as
driving drunk so I'm not sure that you
need additional laws to do that and also
you know I'm not opposed to zoning laws
like I don't think a pot shop should
open up right next to my house right
there residential zoning that's fine
it's a mob of liquor stores though right
man I don't want a liquor store right
next to my house this is correct yeah so
I become a libertarian in some ways on
that sort of stuff the same thing is
true by the way when it comes to the
issue of same-sex marriage so on a
personal moral level I'm opposed to
same-sex marriage I'm an Orthodox Jew
and I believe that a man and a woman
were made for each other when it comes
to government involvement I don't think
that's anybody's business I think a lot
of things I think adultery is bad too
I don't think the government ought to be
involved in adultery i I'm so strict I
don't think premarital sex is a good
thing right I've been very vocal about
this I was a virgin until I was married
my wife was a virgin until she was
married I think that's a good thing
so I think the government has anything
to do with any of those things no I
don't I don't think it's any of the
government's business it's consensual
activity there are no externalities so
what exactly is the government getting
involved in and when the government gets
involved in stuff then there are
externalities right once the government
starts to cram down its vision on people
then you start to get unintended
externality so for example with the let
with the legalization my view on
marriage is that the government should
get completely out of the business I
don't think the government should be
involved in straight marriage I don't
think it should be involved in gay
marriage I think the government should
be out I agree 100% and the reason that
I say that is because as a religious
person right who believes in traditional
marriage I have to I have two marriage
certificates I have the one from the
state that I don't give two craps about
it's buried somewhere in my garage and
then I have my religious marriage
certificate which meant among other
things that I got to [ __ ] up my wife
right I mean like this is the one that
mattered to me and I think that's true
for most religious people the religious
ceremony matters a lot more than the
state saying a thing and the state isn't
incentivizing their people aren't
getting married because I'm like yeah I
need the tax break right so that's a
bunch of nonsense
and once the government decides what
version of marriage and wants to push
that then comes into conflict with other
values so for example once the state of
California decides that same-sex
marriage is on legal par with
heterosexual marriage now I'm worried
about the externality of I have a
religious day-school or I have my
synagogue
my synagogue is a religious institution
it doesn't approve of same-sex marriage
now is the government going to come in
and tell my synagogue
how it ought to act with regard to
same-sex marriage and
that's the government's business so how
about this how about everybody gets to
do basically what they want associate
with whom they want and it's none of the
government's business this seems like a
pretty good happy medium I I'm so glad
you talked about the two things that I
wanted to talk to you about that I'm
sure we disagree one of them being
marijuana and the other one being gay
people marrying each other so let's
start with the marijuana one do you
think marijuana ruins people's lives is
that one of your contentions I think
that it can and I think experience with
no I'm just talking about the I'm just
talking about the statistical overuse of
marijuana among teenagers does have
detrimental brain effects that have
long-term after-effects it's pretty
proven and that's one of the things that
I really I'm glad you said that because
I wanted to cover that but you were in
the middle of a ramp when we were joking
around about six and seventh graders
selling pot don't smoke pot when you're
young you really should it's not good
for the development of your brain same
thing with drinking you know I didn't
smoke a lot of pot when I was a kid I
did it a handful of times until I was
thirty years old but I did drink a bunch
of times when I was young and in high
school and it's terrible for brain
development especially before you're 25
and you're your frontal cortex hasn't
even fully formed your frontal lobe is
like this it's it's it's a developing
thing and there was an article recently
that I posted from BBC that were saying
that you should probably shouldn't be
considered an adult until you're 30
right there saying brain development
doesn't even stop until you're 26 or
20th this is why when people are saying
let's let's lower the voting age you
know what thought what the [ __ ] are you
talking about when I was 16 I was a
chimp was a chimp in high school now
when the the problem that I have with
many people's perceptions on marijuana
is that it's based on ignorance meaning
not no personal experience with you know
and I'll admit I've no personal energy
marijuana so I know you don't I'm not to
be probably should get I that's what I'm
trying to say man I've seen the effects
on on stock prices when people get high
in the studio they jump off the vote
then they come right back up the
marijuana thing is in my opinion it's
another one of those things where people
have this this categorized box that they
like to put marijuana users in like
is the category lazy stoner stupid
delusional it's too widespread for that
I mean there are people I know who are
doctors who yeah so well there's the
jiu-jitsu community is a big one there's
a giant percentage of the jiu-jitsu
community it does jiu-jitsu high they
have competitions party it's not mana
I'm telling you it's because it's not
what people think it is if you've never
smoked marijuana this is gonna be a very
difficult thing to grasp but marijuana
enhances jiu-jitsu because it eliminates
the rest of the world when you're
rolling which rolling is like say if you
and Jaimie we're gonna have a sparring
match that would be rolling like you'd
slap hands and then you go and you
trying to choke him and he's trying to
get you in an armbar and you're going
after it when you do that on marijuana
it's like you don't think of anything
else other than those movements and it
becomes like this very intense
meditation in violence like it's not
violent in terms of most the time you
don't really even get hurt he's like you
get to the point like one of the
beautiful things about jiu-jitsu is you
can grab a hold someone and choke them
to the point where they're going to go
to sleep and you would kill them if you
kept going and they tap around your
friends again and everybody's cool and
you try to do it to me and I try to do
it to you and you really can do it
reasonably hard without people getting
hurt it happens every day
all throughout the world a lot of these
people are high and they're doing this
jiu-jitsu practice in this almost like
trends it's like it's a dungeon state if
you can function when you're using
marijuana I don't care
will you pans and perception things are
off so I mean I would assume there's a
small subset of the population for whom
that's not true right who are overusing
marijuana yes and and that's probably
the majority in fact okay so so then you
know but it's the same way with food I
agree so I don't think there's anything
we disagree about here because I'm not
talking about criminalizing marijuana
use I think that we should honestly
discuss the the evidence that for a
subset of the population there is some
evidence that marijuana is addicting but
it's a subset it's not in everybody
who's on marijuana the vast majority of
people on marijuana are not addicted to
marijuana I think in the same way
through alcohol as well it is there's
people that are going to be addicted to
almost anything and
I think there's there's absolutely
people that are addicted to sugar this
for sure people that are addicted to
nicotine and alcohol and all these
things we let people have the material
addictiveness of marijuana is not
comparable to opioids go for it it's not
even comparable to alcohol or nicotine
it's it seems to be very rare when
people become physically addicted to it
extremely rare and what's what's common
though is abuse and it's common in
everything that human beings consume
it's use is common as we said with food
certainly common with alcohol it's
certainly common with pills and this is
why you know I really believe that the
way to solve some of these problems is a
social fabric problem like an
embarrassing problem it's a social
fabric problem it's a personal choice
problem yes that's why virtually every
solution I suggest is so funny you know
I'm constantly conservatives like me who
are libertarian leaning are constantly
accused of being non compassionate no
it's just our compassionate solutions
don't involve the use of government you
know it's like we're going to encourage
people to make better decisions with
their lives and if you choose not to do
that it's a free country
well you know coming from a religious
background you have this community that
reinforces this kind of behavior and
thought and I think that's one of the
major really one of the best benefits of
religion yeah is that moral fabric and
that community the sense of community
even silly ones like Mormons you know
they're the nicest folks right they
believe something that is [ __ ]
patently insane if you go and read the
Joseph Smith text from 1820 we use 14
years old the [ __ ] that he wrote you
know with that said I mean Alexis de
Tocqueville talks about this you know
early on in the American Republic the
idea is that what makes America very
different is the idea you don't need a
big government when you do have a
supportive social fabric what do people
feel like they're at least oriented
toward a common goal it's one of the
problems that I think we have in the
country right now I'm not sure people
are oriented toward even a common sense
of conversation mm-hmm I mean it's you
don't have to agree on on everything in
order to have a common sense of the
important values that that unify the
country or showing us right now I always
you see I'm Harris is sort of my bet no
are here because he's obviously a
militant atheist I'm I'm in equally an
equally strong believer and yet when it
comes to the things that we would like
to see happen in the country
government policy level but on a let's
have a conversation level and discuss on
evidence level we're on the same page
there's certain core assumptions you
have to make in order for that to happen
in my argument about America and the
West is that those core assumptions are
built on judeo-christian foundations
Sam's core argument seems to be that
they're built on evolutionary biology we
differ a little bit there hmm I don't
want to let this marijuana thing go -
yeah one of the things that I wanted to
bring up to you was this idea that if
you're a religious person don't you
think that there's certain things that
maybe God put here for us to consume to
change your perspective to allow you to
reach new levels of consciousness so you
think it's entirely possible that some
of these things that are here I know you
have an experience but they might
literally have been put there by God and
there's some evidence to say that a lot
of the text from the Bible that in
particular there was a I think it was
the University of Tel Aviv somewhere in
in Jerusalem or these scholars were they
were trying to decipher what it meant
when Moses encountered the burning bush
right and they believed that it may have
been the acacia tree which is very rich
and dimethyltryptamine which is a
psychedelic substance that actually that
the brain produces and it's very common
in plants and they think that this might
have been when he met God and God was a
burning bush that this might have been
some crude translation of them being
involved in some sort of a psychedelic
experience now it sounds outlandish
unless you've had that psychedelic
experience and when you have you very
well could think that you were in a
conversation with God this is on earth
and this is something that may very well
have been lost information or this may
very well have been rituals that people
participated in to bring them closer
together and to reinforce that sense of
community that you do get from a church
and you do get from a group of people
that share more beliefs and values and
there's a there's real good discussion
that a lot of these experiences that
became these religious doctrines came
from psychedelic experiences now as
someone who's never experienced that
before I know this is probably a very
strange thing to try
even wrap your head around its it is
entirely alien until you experience it
but it might very well be religious I
mean I've heard that from other people
who have been who've used those kind I'm
actually made this argument to me too
about use of psychedelics and I mean
maybe apples well okay so this argument
I will say I'm not super fond of the
argument that God made something and
therefore it's ours to use or I mean
like I keep kosher right God made pigs I
don't need them so so I am NOT a huge
fan of the argument that because
something is here or because an urge is
natural therefore we ought to imbibe or
therefore we ought to participate in a
particular activity you know one of the
things that I that I'm very big on I'm a
rationalist when it comes to religion as
much as you can be a rationalist with
read religion to the extent that I think
that it's up to us to use our reasonable
faculties to determine the proper use of
things mm-hmm so which is why you
shouldn't overuse drugs even if you're
going to use drugs this is prior to the
problem of making things illegal you
make things illegal then you really
don't know what it is or how it affects
the body or what's the right dose or the
wrong dose and then people get involved
in these terrible situations where
they're taking things they're just
guessing I mean there's truth but it's
also true that on a social level I'm not
talking about legal because we totally
agree on legal level on the social level
there's a couple of things that are true
of for example the Orthodox Jewish
community low rates of addiction because
people have that social fabric they
don't feel the necessity also yeah as
you say substance use in moderation can
actually be quite a good thing so low
rates of alcoholism in the Jewish
community and part of that is the fact
that you are given kiddush wine from the
time you're a kid right I mean you
actually our D stigmatize yeah it's D
stigmatized and the idea is that in its
proper context this could be a good
thing right so I'll admit I don't know
enough about the proper context of
marijuana to know when it would be a
quote-unquote good thing and so can be a
good thing so and also I'm you know I
don't the truth is I don't enjoy
drinking right I'm not I'm not a drinker
I don't enjoy
I like reality I like living and real
and you know I like experiencing it
totally sober so I've never really felt
the urge to do any of that stuff I hear
the pitch
I hear the pitch but I've never really
felt
the interior designer need to understand
that I think that what we're dealing
with though is perceptions that have
been molded by laws that were shaped by
tyrants that's what I think I mean again
that's totally possible and plausible
yeah and it's historically accurate I
mean when it comes to prohibition
prohibition with alcohol didn't work
prohibition with drugs is just making
the cartels bigger that's causing men
like drunk sir don't like drugs
government intervention ISM is generally
a giant fail
I think our perceptions of what is good
for you and is bad for you is also based
on laws that the government created
ignorant Lee the sweeping psychedelic
Act of 1970 which made virtually
everything psychedelic that they could
they missed a few things
evening slipped through the cracks but
all of the tryptamines and most of them
psilocybin LSD all that stuff was made
completely illegal by people really
didn't even know what it was and a lot
of that is why we based our ideas of
what's good or bad for you it's it's
based on what is legal and what other
people have done with it on this area
I'll admit not only complete
experiential ignorance but a complete
evidentiary ignorance so I have an
examined the evidence I really don't
have strong opinions on any of this I
think it's one of the bridges that we
all could use between conservative
thought and liberal thought particularly
for people that are dying it's one of
the things that Johns Hopkins found and
so there's been other studies done and
there's been therapy done on people that
are dying of terminal diseases and they
give them psilocybin and when they give
them these mushroom trips they have
these beautiful experiences where they
completely accept death and it's almost
a universal reaction to it that they'd
like the the amount of people who still
experience a positive benefit months and
months after the experience while
they're dying that they they say this
was an incredibly moving and powerful
moment in my life that allowed me to
accept the fact that my time here is
done
mhm I mean listen if that's something
that works for people and that's what
it's designed to do then it's designed
by God literally mine that that's fine
I think there's also the generalized
religious counter-argument that there
are no shortcuts to nor no shortcuts to
happiness so let's pose this I don't
think well this is the question right I
mean like let's say that I could
guarantee you the tomorrow you're going
to be a happier person all you have to
do is take this regimen of of drugs that
you're gonna take every day and it's
gonna make you a happier person a more
well-rounded person but it's gonna
permanently change your brain
chemistry's that's something that you
think is good or is it something you
think is bad because from a religious
perspective there's an argument to be
made that these are this is work you
need to do on yourself without outside
aid if possible if there's cases where
you can't then you can't but yeah you
know interesting experiment turns
McKenna had a line about that he said
that there was a joke about there was a
monk and he met Buddha because Buddha
came to town and he said Buddha he
wanted to impress him he said I
practiced the city of levitation and I
have done this for 10 years and now I
can walk on water and the Buddha says
but the ferries only a nickel what are
you [ __ ] waste your time like you can
aid the progression rapidly with
psychedelic drugs and this is something
that ma you know do you know about maps
and their work with MDMA and soldiers
that have had PTSD not so much no it's
it's phenomenal by giving these soldiers
MDMA therapy meaning they they give them
MDMA which is essentially what people
think of as ecstasy the street they give
them pure MDMA and then they assist them
with they actually have a psychologist
sit with them a therapist and they go
over all these details of these
traumatic events and they come to peace
with everything and they've had profound
benefits for soldiers and for we some
combat journalists different people that
have been over there and have
experienced you know the horrors of war
and and just general PTSD maybe people
who have experienced violence attacks
there is shown to be one of the very
best things we've ever discovered for
helping people get past so here's to me
and I'm think about this on the fly
because this is stuff I don't think
about very much but it's it's there's a
complex moral equation to the extent
that if you're talking about somebody
who has
PTSD somebody has a condition and the
only way to help that condition is to
use these drugs I've never had a problem
with any of that stuff right I mean I've
my grandfather was was schizophrenic and
by may be bipolar maybe schizophrenic
the diagnosis is not exactly clear they
prescribed him lithium made him a lot
better would he have been better off
struggling with the schizophrenia of
course not it's much better that he
should have the lithium and then be able
to live in his rational mind yeah so
when there's a problem using drugs to
get past it and and work with it is a
good thing you do run the risk of the
sort of brave new world situation where
you have a group of people who have a
certain level of air SATs happiness that
is not driven by a point of view but
more by just the chemicals in their
their body the chemicals affect your
point of view well that is a hundred
percent true but are you Dhruva Hari
talks about maybe this is the future
right he talks about the idea that maybe
the future is we just drug ourselves
until we're happy basically more that
happiness is the drugs because if you're
a scientific materialist that's what it
is happiness is just a bunch of
chemicals flowing throughout your body
so if you can bring them in without self
change but I do wonder whether that robs
people of a certain level of purpose
that the struggle is part of being human
I think we're changing what it is to be
human just by carrying around phones and
just I mean that's that's true but I
think that that's again one of the
things that I think makes being a human
worthwhile is the idea that you are
struggling I think I think the struggle
is actually meaningful and I think
that's why religions tend to set
prophylactic rules sometimes for good
and sometimes for ill so for example I
I'm addicted to my phone I mean there's
just no question right it's it's in my
hand all the time and but from Friday
night to Saturday night it's off I can't
look at it I'm forbidden from looking at
it and this breaks the cycle at least
for one day a week and that's a good
thing that makes me better as a human
being it's a limit I set for myself and
then a limit that I abide by and if you
believe in in self mastery where's the
happy medium between self mastery and I
need a little bit of aid and I think
that there there is a happy medium there
but I'm not sure that that your drugs
are the answer to I don't think you're
suggesting drugs or no there's also a
problem with the word drugs that
everything is under that blanket and
that blanket can be entire
we're extremely positive there's a
priori it too I mean not accusing you
but that that term it's a problem it's a
problem term because what these are are
substances that are psychoactive and
some of them can be extremely beneficial
and some of them have short-term
experiences that last with long-term
results and I don't think that there's
enough knowledge that I don't think the
people that are negative against it have
experienced enough of it or have looked
at it in an objective rational way
because I think it's something that
could be here take a perspective to give
people a chance to think outside of
their normal conditioned way of thinking
that might have been established by
their community or by their church by
their neighborhood or whatever it is
sometimes a little bit of a break a
little bit of a mental break from what
you're experiencing and the vibration
that you exist on almost every day to
separate from that and to get a look at
it from the outside
sometimes it allows you to have a
renewed perspective that can enhance
your life greatly as long as when people
re-engage their re-engage thing this is
what we share you and I are both
discipline people it's one of things I
really respect about you you're a very
hard worker you're always on the ball
you're very disciplined and I know that
a lot of conservative people admire that
and they mire that in folks and they
think that people who are liberal are
not disciplined they think that they're
lazy it falls into this like weak beta
male sort of category of people that are
progressive and liberal and I think
that's I think that's a misunderstanding
I think you guys you and I both agree
that the struggle is very important but
I'd struggle physically so that I don't
have to struggle mentally I struggle
physically so that I can have a better
way of looking at things with less
stress so we have this shared belief
that things should be a struggle Meister
I forced my struggle on myself so that I
can have a better perspective and this
is something that you and I differ on
like I think you exercise right yes
often you do it
every day yeah makes a big deal yeah
it's yeah I mean I think we we both
understand that struggle is a it's an
important part of understanding yourself
yeah if you do not push yourself you do
not struggle you're not gonna really get
who you are what your boundaries are and
if you're self-indulgent if every day
you're stuffing things in your face that
you want to like it's good to have a
rule like hey for this next month you
can't eat this or you can't do that or I
want you to start fasting 16 hours a day
is it that hard just eat for 8 hours a
day and fast for 16 but no but that's
just doing something like that and
setting these guidelines for yourself
and putting yourself into a disciplined
state can be extremely beneficial like
Jocko Willie coy says discipline equals
freedom it's a great formula and it's
real well it and again it is the basis
of a lot of religion I mean a lot of
religion is very practice based it's one
of the reasons I like Judaism as opposed
to other religions they very practice
based religion you know sometimes you
can take that too far in one direction
which as I say you need to balance
reason with with dictates right that are
meant to make you better but that goes
all the way back to Aristotle I mean
Aristotle talks about how you have to
practice to be good right you have to
practice to be virtuous what makes you a
virtuous person is acting repeatedly in
accordance with with right reason and
that is setting rules for yourself right
that is not violating every rule and I
think when when we talk about on the
conservative side you know folks on the
left being lazy I don't mean that in
terms of work I mean Mark Zuckerberg is
a hard worker I assume I think Jack
Dorsey when he's not getting bitten by
mosquitoes seems like a hard worker but
you know most most of the people most
people have jobs are hard workers I
don't think it's about that I think it's
it's it's a certain perspective on the
necessity of rules hmm and and the
mindset that if I don't know what a rule
is for I'm going to remove it so G K
Chesterton has this this very famous
kind of contrast that he draws between
people who tend to be right-wing
politically and people who tend to be
left-wing politically he says people who
tend to be left-wing politically you're
walking through a walking through the
woods and you come across a fence you
don't know why the fence is there and
you say I don't know why this fence is
here I'm removing it and the person
who's right-wing walks through the
forest and sees the fence and says I
have no idea why the fences here I'm
gonna go find out why the fence is here
and then maybe I'll remove it and that's
the the kind of Burke
and conservative attitude toward rules
the the attitude that this rule was put
here for a reason now maybe the rule
sucks maybe the rule has to go but let's
try and figure out what was it the root
of the rule before we just wipe out all
the fences and then try to rebuild from
the ground up all these new fences and
that's especially true in a civilization
that's the most prosperous and free
civilization ever created I mean if the
system really sucks that would be one
thing but I think people are kind of
ungrateful about the fact that we live
in the best possible time in the best
possible place yeah that's just that
that's the reality and everybody who's
so negative about living in America it's
like okay in 1900 one in ten American
children died in the first year of life
in 1850 the average life expectancy in
Europe was under 40 so what are you
talking about what are you talking about
like our biggest problems today really
for the vast majority of people is that
we are too fat or that we are we don't
have a job but we still have somebody
who's basically making sure we have food
like starvation is not a serious problem
in the United States there's a problem
of poverty there's not a problem of
widespread starvation in fact poverty
tends to align with obesity you know
that this is a pretty unbelievably great
society so maybe you ought to look back
at the roots of that society before we
start willy-nilly tearing up all of the
all of the moral boundaries I think you
and I agree that this is the greatest
time ever to be alive I think what these
other folks are saying is that we can do
better
and I think we all agree with that but
sure but to classify this time as being
a terrible time is I think wholly
inaccurate by the way I hate it right
and left that's one of the reasons it's
one of the reasons why I think there's a
certain point where the trumpian
populace right meets the Bernie Sanders
populist left and that is them walking
around saying how much things suck and
it's like no no that's that's just wrong
I'm a long time it's amazing time for
communication - it's amazing time for
people to kind of understand other
people's perspectives and points of view
which is one of the reasons why deep
platforming and in silencing of
conservatives even though I'm not
conservative bothers the [ __ ] out of me
yeah I just think it's it's a it's a non
harmonious action in a time that I think
could lead to people having much more
open and much more balanced
communication I mean this should be the
time when we are having more
conversations and more fun with each
other and where we are feeling more
entrepreneurial we have a better social
safety net than
so what one of the statistics that
really bothers me is that the level of
American mobility has declined rapidly
in the United States so the number of
people who are leaving their home states
who go somewhere else to work a job for
example is that decades low why it's
easier to get anywhere
now there's 7 million unfilled jobs I
keep hearing from you know folks who I
you know personally like people I talk
to Carlson that you know you grew up in
this small town and the town is dying
the industry left well you have the
government somehow owes it to you that
you get to grow up in this town and stay
in that town even if all the industry
left and I just think to myself by whom
who gave you this guarantee that you get
to stay there and I know listen I'm I'm
a lucky guy I grew up in a two-parent
household we grew up wealthy but we were
middle middle-class like I grew up in a
small house in Burbank with two bedrooms
and I had three sisters those me and my
three sisters and in one bedroom and one
bathroom for six people
that's not poor that's middle-class
that's a great life and I understand
some people don't have that life but one
thing that is guaranteed to you is the
opportunity for adventure in this
country so go and move like why are we
inculcating a feeling of victimhood in a
society where if you make the right
decisions you will do well I mean not
you might do well if you make basic
basic right choices you will finish
better than you started in American
society I mean we're talking like the
most basic choices like finish high
school and don't have a baby out of
wedlock and get a job like you do those
three things and the Brookings Institute
says that you will not be in permanent
poverty in the United States like that's
amazing that was not true for the vast
majority of human history for the vast
majority of human history you did all of
those things there wasn't high school
but you did all the other things and
then you were lived like a serf on a
farm until you died at age 37 of
diphtheria or something so it's it's
just the the lack of optimism in a
society where it should be running
rampant is kind of astonishing to me
well it's perspective right I mean rich
kids grow up with this perspective of
constantly being rich and people grow up
with this perspective of you know how
they view the United States is this
negative thing or that they don't know
how to change their life they don't know
how to take action because they haven't
had anyone around them that's done it
that's part of the problem with
small-town mentalities is that you kind
of inherit the vibe of the people that
around you
and if they're ignorant or if they're
their shallow-minded or if they're
they're stuck in this one town and
they're never gonna leave and you get
caught in that vibe you can one day wake
up and you're 32 and you've never done
anything I mean this is Vance talks
about in hillbilly ology the people who
are in these small towns and they've
basically been told that they have two
choices they can go on welfare or they
can leave yeah
and it's like a final going welfare you
know everybody around me is why not
there's nothing morally deficient about
going on on welfare it's actually one of
the the bigger problems I have with the
welfare state generally is that it
disconnects the person receiving the aid
from the person giving the aid the one
that like in our religious community to
take an example there there's a time a
few years back where a guy came to me I
bought some art from him he's an artist
and really does good work he came to me
and he said my family doesn't have
enough money to make the rent this month
can you offer me in advance on art that
you'll buy somewhere down the road and
of course make sure so I assign him a
tract and he understood that five years
later he came back to me and he said you
know you still haven't bought that piece
of art I owe you a piece of art because
he knew who gave him the money right and
so he was willing to understand that
that was an act of charity and he wanted
to make sure that that that was paid
back he said this in Cinderella man
right with Russell Crowe that moment
where he makes money he walks back in to
the welfare office and he rolls out a
wad yeah like that that feeling that the
government isn't just a giant cash
machine that is exist you pay your money
but that that money actually comes from
somewhere either it's coming from the
future because we're gonna have to pay
back the debt or it's coming from
somebody's tax money and that we all owe
something to each other right and by the
same token the what what I owe to my
neighbors is that if they're in trouble
then it is my obligation as a good
person to try and help them out on a
personal level yes right and the charity
and religious communities is extremely
high that's that's the social fabric
that I'm talking about yeah without
without that sort of dutiful sense to
one another you can't have rights
because if you just have rights then and
and no duties then there will be no one
to take care of each other it's why
while I'm libertarian when it comes to
government I'm very conservative when it
comes to they need to build a social
fabric in communities and and and have
people with working families and in
communities of working families yeah I
really think that that's one of the best
things that comes out of religion is
when you have a tight-knit community
like yours and you do have that sense of
charity
well you really are a community of
people that care for each other and look
out for each other the problem is of
course doing that large-scale and then
the problem is doing it in some sort of
a nondenominational way where people
they don't have to have the exact same
beliefs but they still share these core
values of community and taking care of
each other I mean that's what people
really benefit from when they've done
studies with people when they show
happiness and what is happiness
correlated with it's almost always it
correlated with friends and loved ones
and family rights the most important
thing can have and when it comes to
diversity know there's the slogan that
diversity is our strength well there's a
Robert Putnam as a sociologist over at
Harvard he wrote an entire book about
the social fabric called Bowling Alone
he was kind of the the pioneer and the
idea of social capital and what he said
is that he went in with the to writing
this book with the idea that diversity
is our strength and then he did some
research and what he found is that
ethnic diversity only correlates with
two things these are his words increased
tv-watching and increased protest
marches that's all it unless unless it
is within the boundaries of a common
goal so if you walk into a church very
diverse ethnically everybody's got the
same general goal which is we're
worshipping God in one particular way
and we believe in a certain core set of
values and now diversity is great your
experiences come to bury or you're all
aiming in the same direction he gives
the example of the army you see a bunch
of people who go in diverse group of
people diverse races different
backgrounds and when you talk to those
guys while they're serving or after they
leave they don't give a crap about the
diverse backgrounds of the people they
were serving what they're all aiming
their guns in the same direction well in
the United States we have to be aiming
our guns in the same direction or we
can't really have a functioning social
fabric at all and I'm perfectly willing
to give charity to people who I don't
know who still believe like I do that
America is a fantastic country rooted in
immutably good principles but that
starts to break down when I'm being
asked to give charity just on a personal
level to somebody who believes that
America is fundamentally evil and needs
to be torn out at its roots and replaced
with something better right because now
we're not aiming in the same direction
so on a human level I care about you but
I'm a but on a social level if I have a
choice between somebody who basically
agrees with me about fundamental values
and somebody who is diametrically
opposed I'm gonna give my money to the
person who basically agrees with me on
those fundamental values and again I
don't think those fundamental values
have to be religious I don't think you
have to be a god believer to recieve
charity from me or I don't think I
should have to
an atheist receive charity from you but
I do think that you do have to take into
consideration a few things and now we're
on the same page personal responsibility
the idea that you do live in a free
country just historically and relatively
speaking this is a free country which
means decision making is on you so man
up a little bit they that the decisions
that you make we should all have
sympathy for people who have had worse
lives and worse experiences but in the
end if you are capable if you're not
fundamentally disabled in some way that
you need to make a plan for your own
life and then you need to do that like
are you more willing to give charity to
somebody who has a plan for how to get
themselves out of the hole of course um
of course you know that but that relies
on that person feeling an obligation to
do that I also think that we you're
talking about with with charity within
the community is so much more there's so
much more connection than charity from
the government when you're talking about
welfare the problem is that there's this
dissolving of responsibility because
it's just a cheque that comes in that
you feel like well this is a rich
country I'm owed this anyway right and
you know and when I was a kid we were on
welfare and we used food stamps and I
remember being very ashamed of it and
feeling really weird that we were that
poor that we needed help from the
government but my parents worked their
way out of it they were young they had a
kid my guess is that my guess is that
the the social stigma probably has
something to do with that meaning that
I'm sure didn't it didn't want to be on
welfare they don't want to be on food
seems like contrast your story with Adam
Carolla's right Adam talks all the time
about how his parents were also on food
stamps and Welfare and they just didn't
give a [ __ ] they were just and he always
resented that he thought that was bad
yeah he said like you could work why
aren't you and that gave him the impetus
to get up and do what what Adam has done
so you know that that kind of it's not
pick yourself up by the bootstraps
helping hands are good but it is if I if
I were capable of picking myself up by
my bootstraps would I do so yeah and if
the answer is yes then we're all on the
same team well there's this is a real
problem too and that some people just
get a horrible hand dealt to the
pressure at birth they're with parents
that really are doing a terrible job
raising them they're [ __ ] them up
every step of the way you're around a
bunch of people that have crammed
everybody's [ __ ] up there's no
examples of anybody that's doing well I
mean it's one of the unique things about
the Internet today is that a kid that's
in that environment can get a hold of
maybe something that you said or
something that you know someone else has
said and start reading books and start
taking in information that gives them a
different perspective and fuel that
perspective with more motivational stuff
and more information in education and
sometimes kids just like you were saying
with Adam Carolla they grow up with
these parents that are just not
ambitious at all so they become very
ambitious and they work very hard to not
be like them I mean sometimes it's good
to see that example but most the time
it's it's just [ __ ] hard for them to
reprogram their head well for sure it's
hard to do that it's also hard I really
think that there's there's a lot of
focus in the country right now on
raising awareness which is fine you know
raise it raising awareness of our
history and all the bad things that
we've done you know good I mean people
people should know about all the good
things and all the bad things right it's
its history its history but this this
incessant focus on the idea that
people's lives are getting better by
suggesting that their perennial victims
in the United States I just don't I
don't understand how that's a good thing
yeah like as a historically a member of
a historically persecuted group if I had
grown up and my parents had said to me
no matter what you do you will be put
under the thumb of the dominant society
that's a pretty horrible message to tell
to a kid and I think that's true for
politicians again on both sides of the
aisle I think you get it from from
president Trump when it comes to some
rural areas where it's like well it's
the Mexicans and the Chinese coming in
to steal your jobs and you're under the
thumb of people who are trying to
destroy you and on the other side of the
aisle people who say well you're in the
inner city and therefore the cops are
racist against you and want to destroy
you and everybody is out to get you and
it's like well how about this how about
like again the single best thing you can
do for yourself is make basic decisions
that are entirely within your control
okay unless you are unless you are raped
god forbid single motherhood is a choice
that you get to make about your life
this is a choice you got to make about
your life finishing high school unless
you are legitimately disabled in some
way I mean especially in LAUSD where you
basically have to be able to read a
third grade level to finish high school
you know just just like these are these
are decisions personal decision making
if you want I've never seen somebody's
life get better by complaining about
reality I've seen
a lot of people's lives get better by
acknowledging that reality is what it is
and then making personal decisions to
make their lives better and that's
considered non compassionate but it
seems to me the the essence of
compassion sometimes is saying at least
make the baseline just say if you make
the baseline decisions and then you fail
we can talk about what happened I don't
think it's non compassionate
I think it's pragmatic and I think
you're right but I also think that
there's some people that are there in
situations that require something
external to assist them there they're
the way their life has been set up and
this is what I think when people think
about compassion and people pulling
themselves up by their bootstraps if you
have a real if you really have an honest
and accurate assessment of extreme
poverty and terrible neighborhoods it's
not as simple as do something good to
better your life part of it is you got a
[ __ ] stay alive certainly you're
surrounded by people who either have
committed crimes or will commit crimes
you mean one out of every four people
you run into might be a criminal in the
worst neighborhood in the country for
sure and but I think we have to this is
where we recognize what government is
good at government is good at two things
cutting other people cutting checks from
other people's money they're great at it
and they'll see that they're right on
top of those parking tickets by the way
to make sure that they and they're
amazing at it so seizing your money and
paying money they're very good at and
and pointing a gun at people right these
are the two things that government was
built to do was collect taxes and pay
out money and then point guns at people
right this is what government does so
which of those two things would you
apply in a situation where there's just
a complete lack of social capital
because cutting a check isn't going to
do it alone where does that check go to
the parents who are not doing not able
to protect their kids it's one thing if
you're enabling the parents to move out
of that community or something right
but that's why I say you have to attach
if you're gonna do the government
welfare thing you got to attach it to a
plan it can't just be here's a check
enjoy your life because what is the plan
look I don't think one of those terrible
communities you live in an apartment
complex so I mean here's the reality I
think that the plan very often when it
comes to a crime-ridden area is the
other side of what the government does
which is you need more cops in that area
I think that the the great lie that
though that these community
is that our crime-ridden I'm talking
about white Appalachia and I'm talking
about yes a black inner cities these
these communities do not need fewer cops
they need more cops because at the
precondition to investment in those
communities and increase tax dollars in
those communities an increased social
capital in those communities is people
not getting shot every five seconds yeah
I mean that's that's why the worst thing
that can happen to law-abiding
minorities is for the cops to abandon
areas where crime is high it just
doesn't make any sense and that's not
just me saying Jane Leeves reporter at
the LA Times very much on the left has
said the same thing while abiding people
want crime rates to go down like
conditions have to change in a community
for conditions to change in the
community did you ever see the wild
wealth the whites the wild and wonderful
whites of West Virginia no it was a it
was a johnny knoxville did he produce
that documentary i think he did right
dude it's about this family that lives
in West Virginia that is just a bunch of
psychotic criminals is these crazy white
people the kids drinking Mountain Dew
and doing backflips on the bed and
they're all on pills it's bananas and it
gives you this insight like if you are
in this community if you were in this
family and this is obviously a very
extreme family but there's many more of
them out there that have not been
documented if you are in that community
good [ __ ] luck getting out right good
luck the the money that you get other
than welfare is from selling pills you
know everybody's on these pills so
you're all walked out you don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on half the day
you're on opiates I mean it is a bananas
environment and there's a lot of people
like that in this country for sure in in
poor Latino communities and poor white
communities and poor black communities
the idea that these people just gonna
pull themselves up by their bootstraps
it's crazy I just think they don't have
a plan and I think if we really want to
help them that there's got to be some
way where you can give these people the
opportunity to step out of that pattern
whatever that sure community centers
outreach programs whatever it is I don't
know what it is I mean the truth is the
truth is that historically speaking it
was people actually going to church yeah
I mean and there means there's a good
lot of good I've searched going person
right absolutely recognize that there's
a lot of good involved and having that
framework right and that
I'm not sure that that's yeah I don't
think you can create sort of a fake
social fabric with just a government
welfare system like it just it hasn't
worked I mean disability exists I've
been increasing every year it's it's not
this is it's question I asked Andrew
yang actually sorry our episode comes
out on Sunday and obviously andrew is a
big fan of ubi you know basic income and
I'm not averse to the idea of ubi in a
future where legitimately 50% of the
population can't work cuz they've all
been automated out of existence and all
of this but there's one section in his
book where Andrew talks about how if we
cut people a check for ubi then they
will spend their extra time creating art
and engaging in hobbies that they like
and I just thought to myself I mean I
said it to him like people are on
disability I don't what they're doing
right if you're on disability the people
you're talking about who are suffering
they're not out there written poetry I
mean the the rise of the opioid epidemic
and people who are OD'ing on drugs and
all this stuff that's in precisely the
same demographic you're talking about
you're just talking about a check from
one place as opposed to another place I
don't I don't really see how that solves
the problem I think we have a crisis of
purpose yes right now and I don't think
that that crisis of purpose is solvable
on the one hand by changing our trade
rules and I also don't think that that
crisis of purpose is solvable by by
cutting a government check I just don't
think that that's how people are wired I
absolutely agree with you that there is
a crisis of purpose my concern is about
automation and my concern and obviously
I haven't really studied this other than
talking to Andrew yang and talking to
Elon Musk and a few other people that
are proponents of universal basic income
they think that there's going to be such
a massive loss of jobs in such a short
period of time from people that are non
skilled laborers and it's gonna go away
there's millions and millions of jobs
and these people are not gonna have
anything and that it could be chaos
right so there's there's two problems
that come up there and this is where
Andrews book is interesting because
problem number one is that the people
will be poor they won't have a source of
income ubi solves that the other sort of
but does it even that gives them $1,000
a month if you have did right I mean
even if even if you just had a Swedish
redistribution system and the average
tax rate when I was at 60% or something
it might let's say we could solve the
money problem for a second which you
know without tanking the economy which
is questionable but let's say we could
do that we could add trillions of
dollars to the budget
year and we could solve that I'm still
not sure that that solves the deeper
problem which is that when people lose
jobs they lose purpose yes right so I'm
not sure that ubi solves that problem as
I say we have we have a rich social
welfare network in the United States and
we're seeing this stuff happen anyway
you know I'm a little bit I'm a little
bit less catastrophic by a little bit I
mean a fair bit less catastrophic and my
thinking about automation then then
either Andrew yang or you London I think
that people will be able to adapt quick
enough to avoid the problems they'll
realize the jobs aren't there anymore
and they'll just naturally gravitate
towards other profession I think over
time that people will do that but
they're not always the same people when
there's always shift in the economy and
the the ideal economic model has a
trucker becoming a coder right but
that's that's not read that was that
whole learn to code drive people kicked
off of Twitter right apparently if you
say to journalists then that's that's
very bad if you see those codes truck
yeah that's what it was that's you learn
to code to a trucker if you say learn to
code to a trucker then that's just you
being helpful right if you say learn to
code to a journalist then that is
targeted harassment on Twitter that's
where this is it to me well care about
you I can say whatever but it's but yeah
I mean I think that but if you just say
it's a friend hey [ __ ] learn to code
to take people out for it's one of the
best examples of like how censorship
step over steps its boundaries in
becomes almost like satire yeah it's
Israel it's really really like this is
the biggest aggression ever learn to
code later code like that's something
look this is a stupid thing that someone
said about coal miners they really said
that about coal miners it maybe they can
learn to code and so everywhere what the
[ __ ] and so learn to code became a joke
and became something that you would mock
people right there is their explanation
for it was so crazy it was like no then
learn to code got connected with ok
premises are bad they used the phrase
learn to code that means if you say
learn to code you're a white supremacist
look what he lost the frog that [ __ ]
frog that feels good man the Frog they
turn the freakin frog a mean look
yeah yeah yeah I mean as far as
automation you know there's constantly
people saying this is the the Nicolas
Nassim Taleb view of reality which that
the Black Swan incident can happen any
any second so watch out for it versus
the sort of Steven Pinker view of
reality which is the Black Swan incident
is called the Black Swan incident
because it's a Black Swan incident
meaning that it happens incredibly
rarely you know the idea that we are on
the verge of a catastrophic drop in job
numbers because of the automation of
trucking for example I'm not sure that I
buy it the reason I don't buy it is
because you still are going to need
someone sitting behind the wheel of that
truck there are human drivers on the
road it's gonna there will be a gradual
transition away from some of these jobs
with the Andrew yang talked about
radiologists and how radiologists are
gonna be priced out of the market by
computers they can do a better job of
diagnosing tumors first of all awesome
right I mean that's that's good first of
all that brings down cost and you won't
get cancer as advanced that'd be a good
thing and then second of all what what a
lot of Technology studies have tended to
show is that technology just gets
integrated in a different way in
particular career so there will be jobs
that are eliminated for sure there will
be jobs we haven't heard of that will be
created also and mostly technology will
become more of a productivity aid to two
people so this is true in factories jobs
have been lost in factories it's the
best example of where jobs are lost but
it's mostly turn offices right how many
office jobs have been created because
you have computers
what's the War Office jobs exist because
I write by hand do you think that this
is a kin to like a government bailout
like the idea of the government bailout
was like the banks are too big to fail
and some people thought you know what
you got to let them fail so you figure
out why they failed and we'll never have
it happen again if there is this thing
and the government steps in and says
wait a minute I know you lost all your
jobs are going to give you $1,000 you
don't have to figure it out
$1,000 a month and some people go okay
I'm not gonna figure it out now whereas
those people might have gone on a fear
filled journey to try to figure out
their purpose in life because now
they're stuck where their job doesn't
exist anymore so they're put that corner
I mean they have to act there is there
is innovation that comes from from a
welfare check I mean there are people
who become dependent on government then
there used to be I mean that stuff is
true it does happen and listen Milton
for
made an argument for universal basic
income as a replacement for the welfare
system there there is another problem
with universal basic income that I asked
Andrew about also and that was you know
one of the one of the big issues is that
poor people very often people who are
permanently impoverished not people who
are temporarily poor but they tend not
to spend money where we think they ought
to spend money they're not taking that
money and they're not putting it into
education or into the righteous people
hose and cigarettes I mean the average
the average person who is making less
than I think is $16,000 a year spending
four hundred dollars here in lottery
tickets right minutes legitimately just
flushing your money down the toilet so
it's so how do you aren't you just gonna
end up back in the same place you know
in six months where people took that
money and used it in ways that actually
didn't benefit them and at a certain
point the question is are you do you own
your decisions you do not own your
decisions and what level of incompetence
or inability do we say you no longer own
your decisions and so we're just gonna
take care of you on a permanent basis
that's that's really the the question
here I think we're looking at when
you're talking about welfare we're
looking at worst case scenario right
where someone does get dependent upon
the welfare state and does use that
money frivolously and does make poor
decisions but then there's got to be
other people that are single moms that
you know maybe had a kid with some
[ __ ] [ __ ] that doesn't want to pay
and yeah it's a piece of [ __ ] and they
have to hide from them and they're just
trying to feed their kids first those
people exist 200 have a community to
help them out maybe they're not a part
of a church and maybe they don't have a
good group of neighbors maybe they've
had to move somewhere for work and they
got stuck in some place where they don't
know anybody but I think part of this is
to recognize that incentives matter on
both ends so the idea is that you give
some people more money and they'll
they'll do well it's also true that if
you create a welfare system that
benefits single motherhood you will get
more single motherhood I mean the the
single motherhood right in the black
community before welfare was twenty
percent now it's seventy percent in the
white community it was like five percent
now it's forty person you've said that
like out of wedlock children and having
a kid when you're young is like it's a
terrible idea for your life but what do
you recommend to have kids avoid that
are you one of those people that think
they're without that thing on it no
condoms as we're saying right like don't
have don't don't have unprotected sex I
mean like this this is not it's not
my my fake cursing it's not effing
rocket science I mean like yeah it's it
it's not rocket is make mistakes I mean
that's what happens okay but and then if
the government pays for those mistakes
it becomes less so what should what
should happen should the kids suffer no
I mean presumption it be I mean actually
be worked out I mean it depends on the
situation yeah you know if there are
parents available to the kid presumably
the parents the grandparents would take
a pretty active role in the in the
raising difficut also there there well
how about this how about we assume that
if you are old enough to get pregnant
then you are old enough to let's let's
talk about seventeen year old or
eighteen year old
used to be shotgun marriages were thing
that's a good idea
I think the idea of parents staying
together for the sake of a kid that they
accidentally bore is absolutely a good
idea yes I think that I think that it's
a better idea than the man walking away
and the kid being without a man in the
house so you figure a way to work it out
yes and if they were both reasonable
they could do that yeah and I think that
that by the way a huge percentage of
American births in the 40s and 50s were
exactly this or a lot of 7-month babies
in the 40s and 50s like it's something
like 30 to 40 percent of all kids born
in the 30s and 40s and 50s were 7-month
babies somebody got knocked up and then
the expectation was nagging like you did
that you did the crime now you do the
time right I mean puts people in
relationship prison good find somebody
to have sex with who you actually think
is worthy of a relationship right now or
online pornography is available to you
like figured and you're okay with that
on a moral level yeah no but if I'm
going to if I'm going to compare that to
having a baby out of wedlock then yeah
this is what I think about pornography
they could stop now and we're good
forever there's no supply and demand
problem I think you like making it you
guys are a bunch of freaks I mean
there's no it's like a business it's
almost like you have excess houses that
stack up to the moon like there's no way
everyone gonna live in all those houses
why do you keep making house there's no
way one person has ever jerked off to
every video that ever existed it doesn't
it's not possible and it's also like
other forms of media where they just
stack up I never really thought of that
until we have the backlog of Internet
pornography I'm you know I'm a month
behind now just think about music right
there's all the music that existed
before in the 50s and the 60s and the
70s in the 80s and there's new [ __ ]
every goddamn day
it never ends it's this overwhelming
library of stuff that we have to it
would be good if that music changed from
time to time the same song recorded
seven different ways you know it should
do you listen to what do you think I
listen to you do I listen to classic
jazz in classical of course yes you're
so interesting I was I was a concert
level violinist until I was until I was
like 17 you still practice yeah I mean
that the only expensive object that I
own other than my house is violin oh
really yeah is it a Stradivarius it is
not it is it is a it's not that's all I
know yeah they're the two that people
may know or stradun and like a Guarneri
but those those ones are like hundreds
of thousands of dollars this is in the
tens of thousands of dollars
Stradivarius is hundreds of thousands oh
yeah I had a guy who we knew my family
knew had a million-dollar Stradivarius
now it was so big about it was the big
deal well I mean aside from the historic
value of the thing they're not making
any more of them it does play very
differently I mean very differently look
I had a crappy violin for most of my
like really until the last two years I
had a violin that was handed down for my
grandfather that was worth maybe 1,300
bucks and it was a piece of crap I mean
it was a not a good violin if you're
good enough then you can tell the
difference between a really great violin
to play and one that is a piece of
garbage and I was good enough to do that
so that's yeah I mean I was I was a
classical guy I played I played violin
for years my dad was a growing up my dad
was a pianist look at what Jamie just
pulled up the most expensive violin in
the world sold for an estimated 16
million dollars yep for a Stradivari I
never lose value I mean really they
don't this is it this is it's a good
investment the person I know this guy
who offered he's offered a strat it
think it was 250,000 dollars maybe 10
years ago and he's like know that it's
worth like three million dollars to know
what is the deal like what if you had to
explain what's the difference between
the sound that this makes so I mean it
has to do with the acoustics of the
instrumenting the wood quality there's
there's slight variations in the
construction of the instrument certain
parts of it are thicker or thinner and
it is also it's easier to play a better
violin so it almost covers for your
mistakes when you play a bad violin it
tends to scratch and screech more it's
why when you get in the upper register
with a violin you hit very high notes it
can either be very screechy or it can be
very beautiful some of that a lot of
most that's the player some of that's
the violin Jascha Heifetz who's widely
considered the greatest violinist to
ever live you got a Strad lady blunt
Stradivarius cost fifteen point nine
million dollar buy these and then they
lend them out on loan to you know
world's great violinist so there's a
button in the end it really is the the
quality of the player there's a famous
Jascha Heifetz story where he was
playing at Carnegie Hall and some lady
came up to him afterward and she said
you know your violin just it sounds so
beautiful and he picks up the violin
puts it to his ear and he says honey I
don't hear it right now so do you listen
to any other kind of music yeah I mean I
like some classic rock do you yeah I
mean see rocking out yeah I went to
Doobie Brothers concert with my parents
no that's a band that was named after a
joint that's true that's accurate I know
did you feel like like a sinner I was a
rebel that day Dulli Brothers concert
with the other boomers so the other
thing is same-sex marriage there's the
other thing that I think that we
disagree with
well I we agree with the marriage thing
right should be involved they don't I
think where people should be protected
is through assets and you know the
contract yes yeah I think that that all
makes sense to me that all that's though
in terms of like alimony and child
support and all those things make sense
to me and that then the idea that the
community reinforces it which would then
become the government reinforce and all
that stuff that all makes sense to me I
understand it but why do you care if two
gay guys want to get married
um so from a religious point of view
sure let's go family just so you know I
would need a secular point of view first
so the the idea is not that I care
deeply whether two gay guys want to get
married to each other the idea is that
it do I prefer traditional marriage to
say to same-sex marriage okay well let
me let me phrase it this way what do you
think a gay guy is do you think
someone's there making a choice or do
you think that this is how they were
born so the religious point of view on
this and I think this is actually just
the general conservative point of view
on human action generally is I don't
know meaning that for the vast majority
of people out assume that they have a
biological drive to engage in that
behavior but the traditional sort of
will point of view is that biological
drive does not necessarily match up to
the activity you ought to engage in
right men for example have a biological
drive to impregnate many women
that's not something religion is cool
with either right so the the idea is
that rapid religion is cool with the man
being with one woman and impregnating
her but you're not cool with a man being
with a man so I can give you the
religious explanation and I can be the
second one explanation so these are the
religious explanation is that there is
something different about a woman then
there is about a man and a man is made
better through his union with a woman
and that if you pervert the sex drive to
pursue mere pleasure instead of a
lasting relationship upon which the
basis of society is built then you are
forgoing the proper use of your sex
drive right but if you wanted to step in
and argue against that you would say
that just because someone can't get
pregnant doesn't mean that they don't
have a loving relationship that
contributes to society well that's true
but it is also forgoing the more
productive relationship of being able to
bear and we're children and also we're
recognizing that the sections are not
different right and and recognizing also
the sexes are not the same well you know
being with a man is in a relationship
different than being with a woman I
would assume I mean I think that's why
gay guys are gay if it works then assume
that they would be fine with being with
a woman right so that's so that
relationship from a from a religious
perspective is more valuable because
women have different qualities than men
you round off each other's our edges it
changes you I mean you're married being
married changes a man in a different way
that being married to a member the same
sex would write but I don't want people
to have to do it but if you're not
forcing anybody right but I want them to
have the option if you're a gay person
and of course legally we agree right
yeah leave and I keep making this
distinction cuz yes
whenever I talk about my moral
perspective on things mm-hmm then people
immediately assume that I'm a theocratic
fascist and I just want to keep
underscoring yes my personal views on
Dave Reubens marriage of no consequence
to public policy in any way whatsoever
right but I agree with you on that and I
don't think it should be a part of
public policy and I think people should
absolutely be allowed to marry and
divorce and do whatever the [ __ ] they
want to do no matter who it is but why
do you care like as a person who's a
rational thinker it's pretty clear that
people are gay and I don't really think
that this is a decision they make in
term in terms of like I'm gonna make a
clear choice to defy God and be gay I
think they're just good everyone it's a
conflation of identity and drive with
activity which is something that
religion fundamentally reject okay right
so the religion fundamentally rejects
the idea that you're driven to do
something therefore it is your identity
therefore you get to participate in the
behavior that's it that's a chain of
thinking that really so religion if a
man is gay in your religion yes a man is
gay and they're in love with another man
they should just squash those thoughts
and find a woman well ideally they would
be honest with the woman that marries
they're not like we would want ideally
ideally you would still get married and
have children in a heterosexual
relationship if you're not up to that
then you wouldn't get married at all -
when you describe this to a gay man they
will tell you imagine ben shapiro
someone said to you you should stop
being with your beautiful wife and you
need to now marry a man because this is
what God wants you to do so you're gonna
have to stoop this man and he's gonna
stoop you and because this is how the
rules are set up so far the shirts right
well this is how it sounds - gay folks
when you're telling them they have to
find a woman and I like one I'm not
saying you have to find a woman I'm
saying this guy well I'm saying you
can't do X right I'm not saying we must
but say can't but by whose determination
if you decide to participate in this
religion right then there
a buy-in to the precepts of the religion
and the buy-in is okay well no the
buy-in is that you can have whatever
sexual orientation you please but
there's certain activity you can't
participate in so you can be gay but you
can't have gay sex correct
that's that by the way that's what the
Bible I mean if we want to go direct to
the Texas revival it's what the Bible
actually says right I mean even the
parts of the Bible that people really
hate mm-hmm those parts say that a man
shall not lie with a man it doesn't say
a man can't be attracted to another man
that's Old Testament right yeah that's
right that's our stuff right New
Testament it gets a little harsher in
the New Testament in some places Romans
but in any case you know again
when it comes to this is what I'm
puzzled by is the idea that this is a
unique area of human behavior that
religion is supposed to treat
differently meaning religion treats
virtually every human activity like this
sin is a failure to abide by a covenant
right that's what that's the definition
of sin right when when you commit a sin
in Judaism in Avera in Judaism what you
are doing is failing to do a mitzvah
which is a commandment you're violating
a commandment well there are lots of
Commandments that go directly against
what people are driven to do just
because the drive is stronger does not
make it morally more morally non
culpable to violate that commandment so
when people pick this one out and they
say well this one is particularly
intolerant for example I don't see why
it's more particularly intolerant than
saying to a man that you have to marry
one woman or saying to a Jew that you
are not allowed to eat this stuff
aurilla like it's it may be harder yeah
I think there's any question it's harder
to abide by those Commandments but it is
well within religious tradition like
literally every religious tradition that
there's a bunch of stuff you are driven
to do that you can't now again you don't
have to agree with my program I'm not
trying to convert you there's one of the
nice things about my religion I don't
give a crap whether people are Jewish or
not like we we actively discourage
converts but if you're going to proclaim
that you are you know abiding by
traditional Judaism this is the buy-in
right there's lots of buy-in you have to
wear a funny hat sometimes you have to
you have to go to shul on Saturdays you
have to keep Shabbat like there's
there's a lot of buy-in and as long as
I'm not bothering anybody else I frankly
don't see what business it is of
legitimately anybody's what I think
about personal relationships I'm not
imposing my view on anybody else well I
do acknowledge that out of all the
religions Judaism probably makes it the
the most obvious they don't give a [ __ ]
what you do go ahead do you think like
they're not trying to my uncle converted
and when he convert it was a grind man
he had to learn wash it like three years
it's a long time so that was the
religious perspective on that and the
secular perspective when it comes to
valuing traditional marriage over over
same-sex marriage that's a very simple
calculation which is one type of
marriage produces traditional children
produces children in the traditional
biological way and then you have one
parents in the house to take care of the
kid right that's the value of marriage
and and I fully acknowledge that when
the value of marriage shifted from it's
about production and rearing of children
to it's two people who love each other
the case for same-sex marriage against
same-sex marriage when completely out
the window right so you are just
sticking to your rigid ideology in terms
of like what you believe to be a sin and
not believed to be a sin based on your
religion based on this very strict moral
fiber that this religion is operate in a
religious context to me it applies to my
family it doesn't apply to you right is
there any room for growth in that when
people have a better understanding about
biology like it if it was proven if
there's proven like oh this is why a
person develops blue eyes this is why a
person is gay this is why there's
nothing wrong with it it's just a very
oh [ __ ] it's red hair
it's freckles it's gay it's straight
tell me that that homosexual orientation
is a hundred percent biologically driven
and I will almost completely agree with
that I think that there are some cases
where it's not but those are rare but
this particularly by the way the
research tends to show that there's more
sexual fluidity among females than males
males it tends to be either heterosexual
or homosexual research is all done by
dudes want their wives to hook up with
you the paperwork
but but again that it's it's a question
that I've always found actually not
particularly interesting simply because
it doesn't take into account the
worldview generally which is that a
biological drive does not equal excuse
for behaving in a certain way but this
that's where it brings me back to this
like is it possible that these laws in
this religion were written when they're
what mean - who do you think wrote the
stuff do you think people wrote the
stuff or do you think God wrote I think
either way even if it were I mean
because I am a an Orthodox Jew and I
believe that at the very least it's got
inspired and God written right but even
if I believed on a second level that
human beings were that stuff so I think
that people 3000 years ago had never
seen a gay person before like the very
reason to have a commandment is because
certain people in your community are
behaving in a particular way presumably
right there's no commandment not to take
your head and shove it in a meat grinder
well this is also the argument against
pork it's because they didn't understand
trichinosis they understand you have to
cook the meat to 145 degrees and pork
parasites which are very dangerous for
people so I'm not a huge fan of
naturalistic explanations for religion I
think that's a good one though for pork
I mean I don't know like I think you
could make an argument maybe that it
just died in India and there was
horrific x-rays of his head he had
parasites from pork that had gotten into
his body and they had nested in his
brain started developing all these cysts
inside of his head and they couldn't do
anything about it because it was so deep
in his head that if they gave him the
ante and I parasitic medication it would
cost Wehling of the brain and they were
there like it was it was so the story
it's actually pig [ __ ] apparently
because people accidentally coming in
contact with the pig [ __ ] produces this
particular type of parasite yeah it's
not kosher it's more rare but but
trichinosis was pretty common the their
attempts to sort of paint back into the
Bible certain rationalistic explanations
like this make sense though I I think
why else would you would it be bad II
pigs like Jesus loves pigs so what's
going on well III think that the the
reversal of the kosher laws in the New
Testament you know from from
point of view or we don't believe in the
divinity of Christ and that there he can
make an argument that the the Gospels
which were written he was just about fit
and no no we don't believe he's a
prophet what do you think he was what do
you guys mean what I think he was
historically I think he was a Jew who
tried to lead a revolt against the
Romans he got killed for his trouble
just like a lot of other Jews at that
time who were crucified for trying to
lead revolts against the Roman and got
killed for their trouble so he became
legend in story and it became a bigger
and bigger deal as time with a group of
followers and then that gradually grew
and then do the resurrected no that's
not that's not a Jewish belief in Christ
once ya know Jesus then they're their
ones the ultimate yeah you've got Moses
splitting the sea and all that what do
you think happen there what do I think
happened there yeah well I'll go with my
mana D and explanation that there was a
I mean it says in the Bible there was a
strong east wind so there was a
naturalistic explanation for a physical
phenomenon that makes sense
I mean that's so that's what Maimonides
is constantly trying to do is read
nature back into the Bible mm-hmm yeah
that that is the problem with these
texts right is that you're trying to
decipher translations from original
texts which were written in ancient
Hebrew thousands of years ago and we're
told an oral tradition for longer than
that right I mean this is this is where
you know my book which I always hesitate
to pitch my own stuff because it sounds
gauche pitch away but the new book the
right side of history number one New
York Times best-selling non-fiction but
William a you got number one in the New
York Times bestselling really yeah we
sold enough that we knocked Michelle
Obama out of the woods live for a week
so is there protests
well no protests yet but suffice it to
say the New York Times Book Review or
didn't like it but I'm not super shocked
by that but the the basic contention
that I make is that judeo-christian
values on the one hand and then human
reason on the other Greek reason really
that that tradition is attention and
that that tension is where Western
civilization lives that basically
civilization is the suspension bridge
and take certain fundamental precepts of
judeo-christian values on the one hand
and then takes Greek reason and they're
pulling against each other and sometimes
reason feels like it's going to dominate
religion and sometimes it feels like
religion is going to dominate reason and
the best of all available worlds you
have a bridge that is that is capable of
building upon where you can actually
have a functional civilization
and if you lose reason in the name of
theocracy then you end up with
tyrannical theocracy and if you lose and
if it was religion in the name of reason
you end up in some pretty dark places
because human beings don't have a very
good track record of creating their own
purpose creating their own meaning
creating their own systems we tend to
get very utopian very quickly and things
get really ugly which is sort of the
story of the particularly first half of
the 20th century so this is the benefit
of sticking to the rigid ideology that's
prescribed by religion is that you don't
allow the human beings to keep updating
it and changing it because if you do
they will eventually slide into chaos
yes but there's there which is not to
say there's not playing the joints
remember they're certainly religion has
morphed over time
I mean ISM as it was practiced
originally probably in many ways does
not resemble Judaism as practice now
right in fact the Talmud
even says this I mean there's there's
this kind of fascinating and
counterintuitive section of the Talmud
where Moses is it's it's what it's
called the gotta tie which some of these
stories that are just kind of put into
the into the middle of the Talmud where
Moses comes back and he's watching from
on high as a bunch of rabbis in you know
second century Palestine are talking
about Judaism and he's like I don't
recognize any of this stuff like I
brought down these books from the
mountain and I do not recognize any of
this stuff and and God says to him you
know if a God says to him right I mean
this is how this is more if Moses is
pleased in other words he's not Judaism
has always had a common law tradition
we're using reason to try and develop
the ideas behind the commandments and
then try and extend them or broaden them
and I think that's a good thing but you
have to be careful not to completely
undermine fundamental roots or or get
rid of basic precepts in other words you
have to you have to acknowledge there
are certain fundamental truths that
exist there and then there's play as far
as how those are implemented does
Judaism have one of those pray the gay
away traditions no that's not a thing I
mean it's what do they want guys to do
like what say what would you do if no
not to sin but again soon is a sin is a
thing that everybody does
meaning that masturbation is not is not
okay according to Judaism I assume that
a vast majority of young Jewish men even
the Orthodox are masturbating so people
sit
I mean that's that's a recognition it's
it's always again I think I can speak on
behalf of I will audaciously speak on
behalf of both Jews and Christians here
I think that religious people are told
that when they say that something is a
sin this means that they are looking
askance at the people who are committing
the sin and that is not correct I mean
what Judaism and Christianity say is
that we are all committing sins on a
fairly regular basis where we get
uptight is when people start saying
because I have a desire for the sin the
sin is no longer a sin hmm yeah the real
problem is like what why is it a sin
like who says it's a sin so again who
again this these rules you were assuming
are influenced by God right
but clearly written by people well the
this one you would say if you're a
fundamentalist or at least somebody who
believes in the the idea that the Torah
was given by God was given literally by
God but again that doesn't the the logic
behind the rules which you know people
like Maimonides have tried to explicate
the idea is as I said a second this you
can do without God right this part you
can without God the human sex drive was
made to procreate with in a stable
relationship in order to project and
have future generations of people misuse
of that sex drive in any way whether
you're talking about from masturbation
to homosexual activity is therefore a
diminishment of the use of that drive
that's the natural law case against
against homosexual activity and again I
will reiterate for Media Matters for the
one millionth time I'm not in favor of
any of this being encoded into American
law because freedom is freedom people
should be able to send how they choose
so long as they're not harming anybody
else right no but what about people that
have had vasectomies and what about
women that also she isms not cold
vasectomies not cool with it but neither
is Catholicism from what I understand
right right yeah well I'm not a big fan
of that one year experience with but so
if what if a man is sterile and the
woman sterile are they allowed to have
sex both no so yes because there are
ancillary benefits to married couples
having sex like relationship building
right that's not a generalized case
against the favored view of sex right
mmm that's it's sort of like arguing
that intersex
people mean that there's no such thing
as two separate sexes there aren't two
separate sexes and also they're intersex
people who have a condition yes right
and that that's the same thing here the
case in favor of heterosexual sexual
activity does not change based on the
fact that some people can't actually
participate in that what would you do if
a young gay guy came to you for advice
if someone said hey Ben I'm an admirer
of yours I love the way think and follow
your philosophies but I've got a problem
I'm a young Jewish man and I'm gay and I
don't know what to do what would you
tell him to do I mean I can't tell them
to do anything what would you advise
would you tell it would you what help
them to not act out on those feelings I
would say you do the best you can as a
human being and from my moral
perspective you try to avoid sin as best
you can
mm-hmm but everybody sins the problem
does that sin though it seems to me that
it was defined by people that didn't
understand biology because they were
dealing with humans that existed
thousands of years ago I mean again I
really don't think that biblical
Commandments are linked and religious
Commandments generally are linked to a
view of biology meaning that you don't
think so no I think that all sin is a
recognition that we have drives that we
are supposed to forego okay that's
pretty mean that's that's fundamental to
certainly Judaism and it's Christianity
as well I would say Islam even as this
basic precept right when I think we can
agree that there's some real benefits to
discipline there's real benefits to
having structure and and it doesn't mean
that you can't be creative it doesn't
mean that you can't be free and do
whatever you want some of the time too
but I think we can both agree that this
is one of the one of the best benefits
of an ideology and what hopefully a
positive ideology right and one of the
things that I the reason I keep coming
back to the governmental regulation
point is because my view is that if your
view of discipline is not my view of
discipline good on you right like go do
what you want to do like I've never had
a conversation with Dave Rubin about
about him being a gay guy right but you
did say that you like wouldn't go to his
marriage right well I said right as a
religious person I can't say I can't
actively participate in something that I
consider to be a sin but I would go out
to dinner with Dave and his husband
anytime like my wife and I would do that
of course
we'd have him over to our house with his
husband there's no you don't find any
contradiction between your religious
perspective and your personal
perspective in that regard that you
would though you wouldn't be there for
religious reasons but that you would be
there for personal reasons like if it
wasn't would you go to the after-party
like if you wouldn't go to the wedding
would you go to the after-party
anything that was a celebration of
same-sex marriage no wow so anything but
like if we go to the party no I mean
there's a barbecue the next day you know
it's and again like I'm not sure why I'm
not a good party person so I'm not sure
why anybody would want me at their party
I haven't been to a party with you but I
went to a dinner party with you that's
right we had a great time that was a
good time that's good that's a funny
picture man that isn't I don't know what
the [ __ ] to think about that picture
it's certainly true Erik Jordan yeah
that that is a disturbing one when
they'll just just lump you in with a
bunch of [ __ ] psychopath just because
it's convenient for them and it's an
easy way to diminish you that that that
is a that is a thing that I see more
from the left than from the right and
it's really disturbing
I always thought until this clickbait
generation came along I always thought
that especially well you know the New
York Times is obviously the higher
standard but that you would never see
that kind of [ __ ] from progressive
people you would never see willful
distortion of reality to define their
narrative in a really disingenuous way
and it happened so often now yeah the
people get called my favorite is all
right adjacent I don't know that means
it doesn't mean anything it's a new
thing people trying out to try it out it
might go away it's again trying to lump
everybody into one group for purposes of
castigating their motives is yeah you
don't have to have an argument with
somebody if you assume they're not see
so I guess if you call everybody a Nazi
you don't have to have an argument
it is goofy but you know I think when it
comes to the gay marriage thing what
people were really worried about is
people trying to stop people from doing
what they want to do you don't have that
in you that's not you what you are doing
is opposing it from your your religious
beliefs right like if you want to join
into my show that show has religious
beliefs right that's their business by
the way they're like I can't join a
church I assume I don't believe the
things that people in the church believe
you probably could donate you've got to
give the right amount of money well I
don't believe in the Jesus so there's
that there's a Jesus yeah that's not my
thing
right I mean so that's I wouldn't expect
to walk into a mosque and expect them to
change their their standards on religion
I find it really audacious when people
actually expect other people to view the
world the same way that they do and then
expect that they're gonna be catered to
in that way like I wouldn't walk into I
wouldn't walk into a gay own bakery and
expect them to bake a cake that has
verses from Leviticus on it is a weird
story you know that bacon cake story
because it gets bandied about they those
folks went to several Baker's until
someone said no this is correct yeah
they were looking for a court case yeah
yeah and honestly like that's not you
being a civil rights hero that's you
being a jackass
seriously like go to the other bakery
what does people do to you they didn't
have anything to do with you they don't
owe you their cake and if you want a
boycott then boycott them right you want
to get all your friends to say we're not
gonna go buy a cake from these
discriminatory humans fine it's a free
market have at it but this this notion
that somebody owes you their services
that's that's me it's not even a freedom
of religion case to me that one's a
freedom of association case well I think
what the the goal is is to shame a
business into submission and also to to
put it out there in the public eye so
that people understand that this is a
discrimination that does happen with gay
folks well they will go somewhere and
someone won't make a cake for him right
you know and so I think they wanted to
highlight it so if I was being very
charitable and I didn't think there be
an attention horse I would say maybe
that's what they're doing maybe they're
just trying to highlight this very real
problem it's fine but they actually like
took it to the government once you start
pointing government gonna people I get
real uptight so again it's a weird one
if you're if you were just - yeah we do
yeah right exactly right talk about how
much you don't like them fine you know
like I I may disagree with you or I may
with you whatever that's that's fine but
once you start going to the government
and having the government levy like a
hundred thousand dollar fines on family
bakeries because they because you
couldn't find a gay Baker in Colorado
supposedly like um no I'm sorry that's
that's not cool and I feel the same way
if I walked into a bakery I know like
you're Jewish we're not serving you I'd
be like okay you're you're an a-hole but
all right I mean it's free country and
there's a bakery across the street or
maybe I'll just open a bakery next door
to you and take all your business
yeah well it's unfortunate that anyone
would ever think like that
but should it be a law to force someone
to think differently you can't it
doesn't work this isn't this is my point
is it my religious beliefs nobody oh
you're a theocratic and I keep coming
back to I'm not though like I don't want
to force my beliefs on anybody those
those are my beliefs so leave me alone
and those are your beliefs so we'll
leave you alone and if we can't have a
system where we acknowledge that those
beliefs can coexist and we can still
have conversations with each other or be
friends it's gonna be real hard to have
a society when you told Dave Rubin that
you wouldn't go to his wedding
did he get butthurt no pun intended
because because Dave and I were friends
he knows that I have no anger or upset
about him doing [ __ ] Ben come on man
I don't know I'm not a friend's person
so I don't have any friends I mean I
have friends but they're it's like very
close friends and then acquaintances
mm-hmm I tend to keep a pretty close
social circle that's smart
you have so much time in this life
that's pretty much how I feel yeah like
if you're the kind of person where it
feels like a true obligation for me to
drive you to the airport oh not a thing
man I'm not drunk
correct there are people who make money
on driving that's those people but that
that kind of went away for the most part
so if you find someone who's still
asking for a ride at the airport that's
a greedy [ __ ] at this point your
wife or your girlfriend she wants to
talk to you when you drop over the
airport that's totally cool this is but
that's what I mean by my circle of
friendship like somebody where I'm in
the car with them for half an hour and
it doesn't feel like an obligation
but I value community and I value value
people talking and trying to understand
each other and I I've seen so much
conflict that's unnecessary because I
see so much conflict that's rooted in
people not communicating and and instead
of communicating and I think this is one
of the things that I'm most nervous
about with all this deep platforming and
censoring people and the silencing of
people on the right and it's not that I
agree with these people it's that I see
how this is just gonna shore up these
two sides and it's gonna make it a much
more difficult much more difficult
atmosphere for communication for real
understanding and kind of coming to
agreements on things and and recognizing
the things that we all all good people
seem to agree you could try you should
try to help each other should be kind to
each other you should work hard you
should have good morals and ethics you
shouldn't steal you shouldn't take from
people shouldn't lie you shouldn't try
to cheat the government you shouldn't
try to cheat people right just be a good
[ __ ] person and that this this
transcends religious ideologies it
transcends political leanings it really
does it should and we can have a truly
diverse community truly diverse not
force diversity diverse meaning some
people are progressive some people are
conservative some people are libertarian
you can joke with each other we can all
get along together and disagree with
things just not be [ __ ] hateful
towards each other this is possible but
it becomes less possible when people
feel like they're being silenced or
censors it totally right and it's also
true that when you when you castigate
somebody as morally unequal what you're
really doing is you're giving an excuse
to get into their [ __ ] I mean it's like
this is what's really happening here
like if I had a slogan beyond the facts
don't care about your feeling stuff so
just leave me alone you know right don't
get into my [ __ ] like I'm not bothering
you so why are you bothering me and if I
have a belief system that's different
than yours then so the hell what as long
as I'm not bothering you what difference
does it make to you how I feel about
things the only thing about the gay
thing is that it's not you you have a
belief about things that's not you but I
have lots of beliefs about things that
are not me right but they're people that
aren't hurting each other but it's so
what I mean I can believe that people
who aren't hurting each other like I'm
not a fan of prostitution so
like so I'm not a fan of people here's
some prostitutions clearly more of a
choice than I think gay people are okay
moral distinction which I've repeated a
few times was that I'm not a believer
that a natural desire to do something
therefore makes an activity okay but
that's but that's a view that has no
externalities my view has no externality
so in the same way listen I beliefs
about people who eat too much and get
obese because they eat too much I think
it's a bad thing to do I don't think
it's my business you want to do it your
problem like you want to you want to F
up your life that's what freedom is
called resonate one of the seven deadly
sins
yeah again a Christian thing but yeah I
think but it's but yes I mean and I have
I have lots of beliefs about lots of
things that people do and by the way so
do you things that don't affect you
right now this is we all do but as long
as I'm not forcing that on you because
they're no externality is your behavior
I don't see why it bothers you like
they're legitimately I would assume tens
of millions of people in this country
who believe that when I die I will go to
hell right I don't I don't believe in
Jesus and so there are a lot of people
believe I don't believe in Jesus
therefore I am bound for hell that does
not bother me one iota cuz no one's
bothering to me so what do I care I
don't understand why everyone doesn't
take this view if I'm not legitimately
bothering you why should why should you
care what I think like this is this is
what would be puzzling me if somebody
came to me and they wanted my opinion on
something because they valued my opinion
that much I'd give my opinion but it's a
you don't have to care about my opinion
I think when it comes to the gay thing
where people are looking for is to
people for other folks to be accepting
of who they are and I think for a lot of
these gay folks that have been in the
closet their whole life that's the big
things they're always worried about
someone treating them differently or
someone diminishing them because they're
gay then when they hear someone like you
say that you think it's a sin and that
you shouldn't act on your biology even
though you have these urges that you
should instead find a woman they feel
the same pangs of rejection and I get
that I for sure get that but the
confluence between activity and identity
is actually kind of a dangerous one
meaning then the you know the the idea
that if I disapprove of an activity in
which you engage that I disapprove of
you
I just approve of lots of activities
that in which lots of people engage
including most members of my family
including my children a lot of the time
rather not me I disapprove of them as a
human being or that I'm did and saying
they're lesser as a human being
Brian that like we all interact with
people this way like you disapprove of
my view on this I don't get the feeling
you disapprove of me as a human being no
I don't practice religion you obviously
think my religion is [ __ ] but that's
okay I don't care I don't think it's
[ __ ] I wouldn't say I think it's
[ __ ] I think somebody in the
mountains [ __ ] right well I don't
even know if that's [ __ ] what I do
know is that it's a historical
interpretation of stories that were as
much as they could or as little as they
want it to be accurately defined and
written down and then passed on from
generation to generation example you
think the fact that I won't eat pork is
kind of stupid bull no I don't think
it's stupid [ __ ] first of all I
think pigs are intelligent I wish they
weren't wild I have a deep affinity to
pigs
but I also kill them well I mean I
killed wild pigs let me be broader about
this you're not north excuse my soup
there are things about well but I there
are certain things of which I believe or
practice that you that you probably
disapprove or you don't think there's a
smartest or you think that there or you
might not think is the smartest but as
I've gotten older and hopefully wiser I
give a [ __ ] less about why you do what
you do but whether or not the benefits
seem to be worth if the juice is worth
the squeeze
right and in your case I think the juice
is worth the squeeze I think you're a
very successful person you're very
reasonable you're very intelligent
you're an outstanding debater and I
enjoy talking to you and listening to
you on YouTube I think part of that is
because of the fact that your religion
right of your religious I think it's
cross-training
I think in a lot of ways it's like if
you lift weights for jujitsu it makes
you stronger it'll make you jujitsu
better as long as you keep training I
think your discipline from your religion
has there's psychological benefits to it
totally benefits to it there's it's
right I guess that the point is that
we're different people so there are
certain activity in which I
that you probably think well that's I
wouldn't do that skin' dumb okay but I
wouldn't though I would but I wouldn't I
wouldn't I don't want to do it I don't
want to wear yarmulke I get it I
understand why you blew it what would
appall dudes do they put double stick
tape they're not allowed to know you can
you totally can oh it seems painful and
uncomfortable yeah the point is that in
living in a society we all are
constantly disapproving of each other
right politics is just as disapproving
of each other all the time and so long
as we're not forcing that on anybody
else I really don't see the problem
and I think everybody should sort of get
over it like if I don't approve of your
personal behavior welcome to the club I
disapprove of 99% of people's personal
behavior including my own half that do
you how often do you bait people on the
merits of religion or the merits of your
belief system um you know not not super
frequently but not infrequently I mean
like I mentioned that I've had this
conversation with Sam a couple of
different times yeah like well he's he's
so rabid as an atheist but you guys Sam
is more religious than I am
salmon salmon or for religious atheist
than I am like I'll admit questions
about my own religion Sam is very very
convinced of his of his correctness and
in his viewpoint salmon Sam's religious
dude he's a fast moving guy he is I
liked him a lot and and Michael Shermer
I've had on my show to talk about
religion and skepticism and all that I'm
not shy about talking about it I just
sometimes I find that it's it's kind of
a dead end mm-hmm because sometimes it
just turns into I believe in God and
then the person's like I don't believe
in God it's like well okay fine now can
we talk about the stuff we think are the
what are the fundamental building blocks
upon which you can base a society or
base of politics and if we agree on
those then you know the gods stuff I
think God is a better base for those
fundamental policies and and and belief
systems I think free speech
individualism democracy these are based
on a simple verse in Genesis that human
beings are made in God's image I think
that that's a logical leap this is the
case I've made too Sam I don't think
that you can actually get to human
beings are of an estable inestimable
value from scientific materialism if you
believe that human beings are
effectively just animals then I don't
know why they would be of infinite value
nor why I should respect somebody's
belief system simply because they're
human I don't respect animals and if
we're just another animal I there's no
there's nothing
Tate's that logical line if the in fact
for most of human history it was not the
logical line of thinking it was if you
remember of my tribe then we like you
and if you're not a member of my tribe
then we get to kill you
but is that a logical comparison like is
isn't there a difference between
single-celled organisms and the way a
primate interacts with its environment I
mean yes but I'm not sure why that would
indicate any sort of greater existential
value it's not necessarily a greater
existential value but as we were talking
about the value of community and the
value of having a group of people that
you care about this is this is a core
component of being human this is a it's
a core component of this understanding
mind but that's that's rational
intelligent interfacing with the
universe in a way that no other animal
is capable of I'm not saying you can't
get to the point where Sam agrees with
me I'm saying that I think it's less
convincing than Sam thinks it is meaning
there's no there's an alternative line
of thought that says okay you're right
social fabric is great you know that
social fabric is particularly awesome
among me and my friends you know ain't
that great those guys over there let's
go kill them and take their [ __ ] like
that that was pretty much how humanity
works for a very very long time
and the simple and effective idea that
the reason that human beings are a value
is because we are more than just our
material bodies and there's something
that isn't us that is of inestimable
value that's a religious concept and it
has a lot of weight now if Sam wants to
get to the same place and we can build a
political conversation from there that's
fine
my real argument with Sam is Sam and I
go down to the bottom of the iceberg
about 90% of the way we have the same
fundamental value about free speech
diversity of opinion about I think to
mostly in extent free markets you know I
think that we agree on a lot of these
fundamental principles he then says that
he gets those from pure reason I have
serious questions about whether Pure
Reason necessitates those conclusions he
tends to think that those are the only
conclusions a reasonable person could
come to if you properly apply a reason I
don't think that's right what do you
think is happening there what's the
mechanism I think that the mechanism is
that we are common what I said to Sam
when we were debating this in San
Francisco is it's real weird he's a
materialist a scientific materialist a
theist who is sitting across the stage
from me a religious Jew we agree on 95%
of our values so how and his answer
well you know here's where I've studied
I've studied Buddhism I've studied these
philosophies and I've studied science
and is that right I haven't studied a
lot of those things but we have the same
value so why it seems to me a better
historical explanation is that we have
grow up we grew up ten miles from each
other in Los Angeles after 3,000 years
of common history of judeo-christian
development balanced with reason in the
West like location has something to do
with this and that location was rooted
in commonality of interest and
philosophy so I I'm less it's it's
there's a weird nexus I don't want to
get too kind of deep in the weeds here
there's a weird kind of Nexus on what
truth is but where you've heard Sam and
Jordan Peterson debate this that wasn't
saying it was it's wild right and the
truth is I'm closer to Sam than Jordan
on this I'm closer to Jordan than Sam
when it comes to the value of religion
and I'm closer to Sam than Jordan when
it comes to objective truth Sam believes
that there is such a thing as objective
truth
Jordan tends to be more of a pragmatist
he tends to believe that truth is sort
of what is useful to a certain extent
and my I agree with Sam but I'm not sure
how he gets to objective truth from a
scientific materialist worldview why is
there objective truth as opposed to what
you think is what you think being
evolutionarily beneficial how do you get
from that to it's a universal principle
that is objectively true it's it's it's
a bit of a jump well it depends on what
the concept is right like what are you
talking about in terms of I'm talking
about I'm talking about anything that
Sam says is true what makes it true as
opposed to just evolutionarily
beneficial for us to think so meaning
what evolution does is it creates a
series of thoughts in our mind
presumably if you're a materialism hmm
that are beneficial to your preservation
and promulgation of the species they're
not active actually true so if it's
beneficial this is Sam's explanation for
the prevalence of religion for example
say religion isn't true but evolutionary
biology sort of drives people toward
religion so you can have group bonds
that are beyond 150 people or whatever
so why doesn't that apply to math why is
it the two into how do you know that two
and two actually equals four as opposed
to it is evolutionary been evidently
beneficial for you to believe that two
plus two equals four so Sam believes
there's an objective truth somewhere out
there the two plus two equals four I
don't know what evolution has to do with
that sort of stuff so what do you think
is happening that he disagrees with so I
think that
is happening is that human beings were
placed in an orderly universe through
the processes of biology and have a
unique capacity to understand that
universe because we are made in the
image of God this is where I think that
the religious viewpoint diverges pretty
strongly from from Sam's but you should
leave in evolution yes you believe that
evolution was a process that was created
by God
to formulate human beings yes
interesting yeah I mean that's that's
the nice thing about being religious you
can attribute most most everything to
God is it's nice
well here's the thing it's not that
implausible if there was some sort of a
grand plan there would be no regard for
like oh we got to get a rush on this
right making the evolutionary being you
know we're gonna process there's all
sorts of fine-tuning arguments about how
implausible it would be for just atoms
roaming around the universe randomly to
end with with human creation you know
the alternative explanation seem no no
more no less implausible to me like the
multiple universes Theory plausible but
we have no way to prove it because we
can't get to those multiple universes so
how's that testable or the or the now
popular theory that we're living in an
AI simulation not sure how that's more
testable than God not sure how it's more
testable that aliens put us here like
how is any of this time why is that more
testable or more plausible than the idea
that there is a force behind that which
we see that has mind well let's let's
just break this down slowly there's
obviously something that's happening
there's obviously something that went
from the Big Bang to Planet Earth in
2019 with cellular communication and
satellite dishes and obviously something
happened something pretty radical why is
it happening is it happening because of
random events that sort of coincide with
biology and technology and all these
things come to fruition to you and I
standing across from each other talking
on this podcast in front of millions of
people or is this
is this just how things go is things
compete constantly try to get better and
then in this gigantic ecosystem of all
these things competing and trying to get
better one super successful organism us
rises above and continues right and
continues and by far passes all these
other creatures below it and moves we in
our estimation I mean if you if you
really believe in evolution you can't
think we're done right it's got to be
moving towards some rate or product
keeps going until it creates so this is
why I say that Sam is more religious
than I am I think that there's a
plausible argument for atheism I just
don't think that there is a plausible
argument for Sam's moral vision of
atheism meaning that what what but Sam
tends to do is it like for example you
and I have talked a lot on this
particular podcast about the value of
self betterment and making decisions and
being responsible for those decisions
how does that work in an area where you
don't have very well so Sam actively
says we do not have very well yeah
that's a weird it is it is a weird
conversation and sort of a
self-defeating one Sam suggests when it
comes to the scientific method that we
are using science to find out truths
about the universe and we're using
reason seems very big unreason I also
have a gun reason but I don't know how
Sam is defining reason as opposed to
just an evolutionarily beneficial firing
of neurons meaning that that's what we
are at were balls of been wandering
purposeless through the universe and
then he'll talk about making our own
meaning or seeking human human
prosperity or flourishing is the morning
like Shias these are all very active
verbs right this is this is an active
vision of man in the universe right and
I'm not sure how that flows from were a
ball of meat that evolved from another
ball with me that evolved eventually if
you go back far enough from non balls of
meat without any without any free will
without any capacity to choose I don't
know how you build a civilization on
that well there's two different
conversations here one is determination
or determinism rather whether or not you
have free will or whether or not your
life and your actions are being dictated
by the past by your biology by your
learning experiences by external
pressures what is causing this very
clear decision that you make is this
freewill are you
deciding I'm gonna get my [ __ ] together
or all the factors around you pushing
you and funneling you into this this
direction that you it's unavoidable to
you right and that you are not a product
of free will you're just a product of a
lot of different factors right or is it
both
is it that you are the product of your
environment and your life experiences
and you also have free will right and
I'm in the latter group I'm in the
latter group I think as well I think we
also experience great benefit from
making positive choices and then
experiencing like whatever you meet
someone has lost a lot of weight one
things they have this [ __ ] tremendous
feeling of accomplishment yep you know
yeah I lost a hundred pounds like holy
[ __ ] man a hundred pound right like they
get this positive feedback from it
there's there's real good and making
good choices and when people decide to
get their [ __ ] together and make a good
choice they were rewarded the question
is are you doing that because of
determinism or are you doing that
because of free will or are you doing
that because of a combination of both of
those things and can you fuel that free
will purposely through like outwardly
seeking things that are motivational or
things that are educational things that
allow you to kind of remap the way you
process reality right which can be
extremely beneficial and can aid in you
taking steps towards exercising your
free will right well this and this is
why I think that in the end it and right
but I think it's pretty fundamental
question and I think that that's why in
the end I'm religious and I'm not sure
why Sam isn't because he agrees with the
same premises mmm right he'll he'll talk
about self betterment and decisions that
you can make and then he'll write a full
book about why freewill doesn't exist
and I just don't understand how those
two things can coexist
yes it's well I think it's a thought
experiment first of all I think the
whole determinism thing is a thought
experiment because there's really no way
to determine right so you can know for
sure right I mean like there's just no
way to act otherwise I've absolutely act
as if I have freewill
right and we all do and I get angry at
myself when I [ __ ] things up I don't say
well it's just determined as a man right
no that doesn't get you in
and but maybe it's determinism that has
put me in this position where I'm the
kind of guy that gets upset if I [ __ ]
things up right I don't know man I don't
know but I don't know if you know either
that's my take on all these things but
people get really rigid with their
ideology yeah like okay I want to hear
it out I want to hear the whole thing
you know I want to hear it all I think
if you know I think there's a I think
there's no I think there's a lot that I
don't know but I think that there's more
plausible and less plausible I agree
this is where I think people
misunderstand you you have your beliefs
but you're not a god that imposes them
on people and I think we need to be way
more reasonable in terms of the way we
address people's beliefs and I've been
guilty of this in the past I'm sure
everyone has but I think it's a core
component to a healthy community is to
allow people to have their own beliefs
and you know who knows man maybe your
beliefs on gay people will adjust and
move over time as you get older and move
into a gay neighborhood and yeah it's it
it's it's a difference between
understanding people are as as whole
people and then saying that I don't like
some of the things that they do and
simply saying the making the assumptions
because I don't like some of the things
that you do we can't be friends or I
disapprove of you as an entire human
being which i think is not true it's a
good belief system to have if you're
straight and then you go look lock down
don't need to worry about that I got a
problem but if you were gay God down
there'll be opinion yeah absolutely I
mean it would be annoying if you just
always wanted to bang dudes and
everyone's saying no nobody said
religion is easy man it's all what's the
value in it though if you're if you're a
giant homo all right and all you want to
do is go to gay discos a part of your
ass off that's what you enjoy some
people like golf okay
some people some people like parasailing
some dudes just want to [ __ ] get it
on man you want to dress up like the
Village People and go have a [ __ ]
party that's why Santa Monica Boulevard
such a hot spot and you find each other
hey you know do whatever you want to do
honestly do whatever you want to do cuz
menu don't ask me to think that you know
don't ask me to like put my stamp of
moral approval I understand but do you
want to do the like it's free country
this should be a free country not just
it is a free country it should be a free
country it should not be my job to
police your personal behavior right
right right like you doesn't mean I have
to improve it on a personal level right
but I'm a jerk if I want to impose my
belief system on your personal behavior
that affects no one else that's the and
I'm a hypocrite if I continue to braid
you about your your opinion on gay folks
what do I give a [ __ ] with your opinion
correct because you are a reasonable
person and you do you're very polite and
either you're in friends with Dave Rubin
so there you go something there it's
it's a strange thing though this this
need that people have for everyone to
think the way they think and I
understand the need to reinforce your
own thoughts and we're in and and and
argue them and try to figure out a way
to debate that the other person's
perspective is incorrect and your
perspective is correct I understand all
these inclinations that people have but
I think that they conflate that with
bigotry right you know and I don't
exactly I don't think you're a bigot I
don't agree with you about gay folks but
that's one of the few the marijuana
thing is just I just don't think you
have any experience in it right and as
far as as far as disagreeing I think
that we probably don't disagree on gay
folks I think we disagree on identity in
gay and all the rest of it I mean as
human beings you know these are human
beings I know many gay people who I
think are significantly better human
beings than religious people that I know
yeah you know I'm glad you said that
yeah I think it did theirs in a way I
don't have a defined religion but in a
way I have some pretty rigid ideas that
I have in my head about behavior and
ethics and morals and how you treat
people you care about those those are
like they're pretty rigid and I think
one of the things that religion does is
it allows you to have the
sort of ethical framework sort of like
uh you know what is it cost Kapil ding
when you're building like it allows you
to develop a more disciplined life and
it just shows you this is good and this
is bad and it's clear and there's
there's most different in for the most
part it's good for the most part these
are these are good patterns to follow
and I think that I've most certainly
sort of adopted my own somewhere along
the line I think we all do yeah I mean
honestly a value system effectively is
usually a form of religion right so when
you're saying that Sam is religious he's
a religious yeah you're not being
inaccurate there's a lot of folks do
that we we do develop these sort of
principles that we found we're not just
free willy-nilly just doing every walk
all day long no one does that and the
reason I say it is sort of facetiously
but I think that we all make fundamental
assumptions about the nature of human
life and we have to recognize that those
are assumptions you can't it's it's not
reason all the way down you know that
because that tends to actually become
even more inflexible then it's I'm the
only reasonable person in the room my
reasons are the only ones that matter
though it's my reasons all the way down
acknowledge that we're all making some
assumptions and then we can discuss
whether those assumptions are worthwhile
or not yeah the thing that when it comes
with religion in defining whether or not
other people's behavior sinful where it
doesn't involve you that's where a lot
of folks start thinking that maybe these
ideas are bigoted right but it does
involve me meaning that at times
well I'm enjoying every sin that I say
is a sin is a sin that it joins me it's
just that I may not have a desire for
that particular sin meaning I'm not I'm
not holding people to a different
standard than I hold myself nor am i
saying that I never sinned right but you
know that you have different biological
desires than they do you kind of
acknowledge that of course that's true
yeah of course that's true by the same
token I assume that a gay guy doesn't
have the desire to strip a thousand
women which most straight guys do yeah
why do you think if if God has a plan
well I do think you'd create gay people
I mean I think that God creates first of
all I don't think that I'm in a position
to evaluate God's plan if you like gods
if I had to guess people with all sorts
of different challenges and those
challenges span
the spectrum mmm I mean I I'm not so God
sneaks it up on you hey man I know this
is gonna be [ __ ] up but you're gonna
just like dudes like forget about women
you're gonna like dudes and not I want
you to ignore that which I listen to my
old book I don't know why God gives
people drives I don't know why God gives
kids cancer I don't know a lot of things
about God wish I did it would make my
life a lot easier so you think that that
is a challenge akin to any other
challenge that a human being might face
in this life that the challenge of but a
lot harder yeah and a lot more difficult
and a lot more straining and a lot yeah
of course you think there's value in
following that challenge and not acting
on Gator jizz I think that I think there
can be and having sex with one plug your
nose go make a face because your disgust
did you create it did you create a baby
out of that then that is that baby like
a part of your life now that is it that
it's deep in meaningful mmm maybe what
about in pass there's a lot of gay guys
having kids what about people saying
living their truth I'm living my truth
bench pure oh well I mean as a general
rule living my truth is there's living
your opinion which is fine like live
your opinion how you want again that
gets back to do what you want as long as
it's not bothering me living my truth is
a different thing that's one of them
social media creations like living my
truth such that's just [ __ ] I'm
sorry it's there's no such thing as your
truth there is not truth and then
there's your opinion and we do have if
we're purposes of conversation at the
very least it's deeply irritating when
people say living my truth because it's
like I disagree with you and then like
well you're you're disavowing me as a
human being no I just disagree like you
can be you you can do it you on like you
do that whatever man
yeah like I'm how did I become the most
loosey-goosey libertarian Leanback guy
in the world in this society how is this
possible the most uptight person I know
how is this a thing well you know as
well as I do that the further you go
left you you you you reach the same sort
of gsella tree that you do when you go
all the way rice is correct you meet
these crazy people that are just
completely connected to their idea of
being correct and they take the most
rigid stance on all these issues on the
left side or on the right side and it's
so goddamn common
human behavior Saul so incredibly boring
yes I mean there's just nothing to
discuss with with yeah I agree and
that's one of the reasons why it's so
disgusting when people mislabel people
like there was an article that connected
me with Richard Spencer like what in the
[ __ ] like that is such a disingenuous
thing to do yeah they know what they're
doing they're they're trying to get me
to react to it and talk about it and get
more glitz but it's horseshit yeah like
anybody who but if you are locked into
that far-left ideology as far left as
you can go and it's one of the problems
with ideologies that have these
extremists is that you believe in a
percentage of the things these people
say but then they go way too far with it
but you're connected with them you're
connected with them because you're a
part of that even though you don't have
a similar notion steven pinker got
browbeaten over suggesting that failure
to ask questions and give plausible
answers gives excuse-me credence to the
alright that that if you do a say he did
a whole speech where he said listen
there are lots of conversations about IQ
and race and they all write loves these
conversations because then they then
they suggest wrongly the black people
are inherently unfit and white people
are more fit and all that kind of stuff
and he says there are great ways to
explain how much of IQ is is cultural
how much can be changed how much is
genetic how much that actually matters
in terms of real-life outcomes we can do
all those things but when you say don't
ask the question stop asking the
question then you make people Google and
the only thing that they will Google and
find our answers that are given by
people who are actually all right right
he got ripped as alright for this yeah
it was don't allow people to push into
all right answers by failing to give
them proper responses or by throwing
them out the window and then people like
well you're all right now because you're
saying that people should be able to ask
questions it's almost like it's just
like it's the exact same version as
people in the religious community where
it's like you know I used to go to
Sunday School and then I asked him any
questions and they kicked me out right
that's that's not how religions supposed
to work that's not how reason is
supposed to work that's not how any of
this is supposed to work right and
there's also when when you're
investigating anything any measurable
thing there when you find a
whatever it is like these people like
Asian folks are better at mathematics
European folks are better at this and
like what is what's the reason for that
like what what's let's find out is it
cultural
is it biologicals it's something can we
learn about how human beings evolved and
adapted why are nigerian so smart like
there's so many Nigerians that come to
this country they thrive they thrive in
business they're extremely motivated
they're extremely disciplined it's like
it's like almost like Korean folks
why do Koreans like it's why are they so
hard-working why are they strive and
obviously these are big generalizations
but what is it about Italians what
wouldn't make some where gold chains and
love mafia movies like what is it those
are my people
what the what the [ __ ] why they all talk
like that like what is that what causes
a any sort of ethnic group to turn out
the way they turned out what are so many
European Jews Nobel Prize winners right
what the [ __ ] is going on over there and
also like what is the impact of the
measurable on how we live our lives like
how much should this stuff matter is
this is this a result of discrimination
or is this a result of something else is
it true that when you group any group of
people together racially or non racially
there will be disparities between those
two groups of people this is just true
statistically like but not asking those
questions and then saying shut down the
questions what that actually does is it
leads people to only get the answers to
the questions from the people who don't
know what they're talking about in many
cases and who are giving convenient easy
and sell flattering answers about the
nature of themselves the fear is it
being used by racists to reinforce their
position right but what you find out is
that those appear your race right and
they'll do that anyway one of the one of
the funniest things about white
supremacist is they're so [ __ ] stupid
and pardon the language like the the
white supremacists are invariably not
the Nobel Prize winners it's it's go to
a white supremacist compound you're not
looking at a bunch of people who are
curing cancer these people pissed me off
in it and this is and now I'll say all
that won't matter the media label me
outright tomorrow except this goes well
the disingenuous media that's being less
and less taken seriously taken less loss
seriously it's it seems to me that that
trend which is a common trend that's
existed for the last few years of these
clickbait t [ __ ] articles and
mislabelling people it's going to go
away because you're your
perspective is not going to be
appreciated it's not going to be
respected if you if you're obviously
making disingenuous statements like that
and I think we're in this weird position
where it's very difficult to find real
journalism and real objective takes on
things that aren't flavored by their
ideology and everybody's trying to shape
everybody and they feel like it's their
obligation they feel there's many people
that write things that feel like it's
their obligation to change your
perspective on national subjects and
things that are important to us it's not
their obligation to just report what's
going on but also their obligation to
flavor things in a way that'll make one
side look favorable to the other yeah
well I'm very much in favor of
journalists revealing their biases I
think that the greatest lie in media is
that objective journalism is a thing
so I'm conservative you don't go to my
site you'll get a conservative spin on
the news that's the way it's gonna work
and guess what CNN's liberal and they
are going to give you the liberal spin
on the news and that's just the way this
is going to work did you see the video
when the Mueller report came out they
look like somebody here killed oh my god
he's crazy
shouldn't you be happy if you guys
believed in Mueller everybody was like
Mueller is the [ __ ] man he's gonna go
get Trump this guy is methodical he's
precise he's voted everything votive
candles with his face on it they could
like bird they were pumped yeah and then
he came out and was like well no
collusion it was like well I guess that
now to cover up it's like what wait a
minute yeah maybe maybe the narrative
has it maybe the narrative has has
trumped the actual job you were supposed
to do guys well it's just so many people
were so convinced and there were so many
people that were making statements that
in retrospect are probably like you
could probably I mean I don't want to
say I'm not a litigious person but if I
was a guy like Donald Trump oh man yeah
there's so many people to sue is it like
it was amazing I mean I remember I was
on Bill Maher's show and we were
supposed to talk about free speech stuff
and like five minutes before and he's
like let's talk about Russia as producer
Kevin let's talk about Russia and that's
like okay fine so we get yeah this is
like right before they switch the topic
for your TV shows well they just tell
you what you have to talk and I comes in
with a clipboard yeah it was it was a
little bit it was a little bit strange
and we got onstage and he's talking
about Trump Russia collusion and I said
what I've always said which is I'll wait
for the evidence to come out and then I
will make a decision as to whether Trump
Russia collusion was a thing and Bill
Maher was like oh I know and Bill Maher
goes you don't you don't believe it was
a thing and I was like well I don't see
any evidence yet that it was a thing
like I see some evidence of attempts to
collude like Don jr. I see some attempts
of people trying to get information but
I don't see evidence of like actual
legal collusion and why don't we just
wait like you guys keep wanting Muller
to give us it like let's just wait on it
and Mark could not believe that this was
my perspective right it was like it was
like shocking to him why should why
should the perspective I'm waiting for
more evidence be shocking to anyone when
it is obvious the evidence is not out
like why is that in any way
controversial it's but wildering to me
well it's because people have this need
to let everyone know that they're on the
right side and they want you to know
that they do believe in the collusion if
you disagree with that for whatever
reason you must either be a right-wing
person a trump supporter someone who's
in denial someone who doesn't look at
the evidence and you're a part of the
problem yep
but the the real problem was jumping to
conclusions
they're obviously seemed to be some
attempts there's there's obviously some
[ __ ] with that IRA company that the
the internet research agency that is
responsible for millions of interactions
with people online where they pretended
to be right different supporters Rossum
they caused conflict like constant
conflict in regards to political opinion
and that's all real that was coordinated
effort to try to change people's
opinions but how much that had to do
with Donald Trump how much did he ask
for you got no evidence also I was
always bewildered by this theory like
did you watch that campaign that was not
the most well coordinated campaign it
was chaos it was chaos
I mean I knew everybody who's in the
campaign like it was a it was a [ __ ]
show then the idea that they're sitting
there but they're but when the mask
comes off at night they call it Vladimir
Putin and then put together a
point-by-point plan on how they're going
to swing this particular precinct in
rural in rural Michigan what are you are
you guys hi what are you talking about
what like if you could attribute this to
any here's a good rule of thumb for
politics attribute everything to
you pity unless you can prove malice the
real problem and this is something that
is very similar to what we were talking
about earlier when you say something and
you say it over and over and over again
and you say it with such conviction and
it becomes a giant part of your news
narrative and then that something turns
out to be horseshit yeah you just
massively empowered Trump that's that's
exactly right
I said for a long time that you know I'm
not a big fan of Trump's fake news stick
because I think he applies it too
broadly I think that whenever it's
there's bad piece of news is like fake
news it's like well sometimes yes and
sometimes no but now that you just blew
a two-year narrative where he was
clearly in Putin's pocket how many
people you think and listen to the
nuanced view of fake news now and how
many people do you think are going to
actually believe Trump when he says that
a bad piece of news is legitimately a
fake piece of news yeah it empowers him
in a in a spectacular manner they made a
giant mistake oh yeah and they blew that
they blew this one in spectacular
fashion and people are still hanging in
there well all they had to do this is
true for so many people right now all
you have to do is not be crazy just stop
it it was talking about the possibility
that Trump has been a Russian asset
since like 1987 or so is that I mean
Andrew McCabe the former FBI director
was asked whether Trump was legitimately
a Russian asset he's like I don't know
it's like you're using the power of the
institution you used to run to spread
this nonsense and you got that from John
Brennan he got it from James clapper
these are all former heads of the
intelligence agencies it just makes me
think the intelligence agencies need to
be wild like her back if these were the
heads of them
I mean if like the heads of the
intelligence agencies are using their
platform to proclaim that they have
inside information about Trump that
turns out to be utter nonsense I'm not
sure these people should have that much
power to like is that what he's saying
or is he saying he doesn't know he
didn't say I don't know he was saying
like I have basically I expect that
Miller is going to indict as a former
intelligence professional I expect that
yeah there's a lot of that it was ugly
Adam Schiff it's crazy now cuz like what
do they do now like how do they rebound
from this if this is there's no let you
say once this is something you said for
two years right you've seen the
compilation video they've done them -
rap music so they're like they put a
beat behind it
have you seen it now I know there's some
great ones some great companies
compilations of people saying possible
collusion possible collusion pop yeah
yeah and there's music that goes with it
and they just cut to possible collusion
with the Russians possible Russian
collusion yeah possible Russian
collusion
it's yeah they blew it in a major way
yeah I mean there's plenty of [ __ ] to
complain about you didn't have to go
with that like the idea was that he was
a treason target-rich environment he
decided to go to he's a Russian traitor
what like it's no way out or something
and it's Kevin Costner he could have
ever beaten Hillary sorry I mean I do a
little bit right now like I wanted to
ask you one more question what do you
think about this Chelsea Manning
situation because I don't know exactly
what happened other than she's in
contempt of court and so they've got her
in solitary confinement now
this is about testifying closely I mean
my understanding is that Chelsea Manning
who okay so here's where we get cuz you
call her Bradley no he changed his name
to Chelsea
he is a biological male are you dead
naming as well unless we were talking
about when he committed his crime to
which point he was actually Bradley as
opposed to trustee right so if we're
talking about so he person was convicted
that was a male and then Bradley Manning
personally known as Bradley hey if we're
talking about a human being who's
currently in jail that is a male who is
currently known as Chelsea so so my
understanding is that Bradley is that
Chelsea Manning is a refused to hands
over information that he was legally
bound to hand over about WikiLeaks
mm-hmm and now there were complained
that he's being held in solitary but
that's not true apparently and that he's
being mistreated I do find it weird that
the same people who are complaining
about Donald Trump coordinating with
WikiLeaks are very upset about Chelsea
Manning going to jail for coordinating
with WikiLeaks you're gonna need to pick
one of the others WikiLeaks Bators
WikiLeaks not bad yeah what is WikiLeaks
it's only dependent upon whether or not
they're supporting the narrative that
you want that's exactly right and it's
the anti few leaks was very good
remember exactly was right and left by
the way like their people on the right
where's like Julia saw Julian Assange is
the
worse and then 2016 happened like Julian
Assange now there's a person I can
really talk to it's like well no I'm
pretty sure Julian Assange is a
WikiLeaks good information suggest they
are Russian front group and take make of
that what you will
end of story do you think that they
became a Russian front group to try to
stay operative and stay safe because
they were obviously being attacked by
the United States government and in
danger being shut down and then they've
no enough about WikiLeaks to really get
into it
I don't historical but I know that he's
been trapped in that embassy for since
2012 yeah I mean I hope that he's got
some video games or something in there
[ __ ] man he's been in there for like
seven years now right that's a long time
I can't go outside no sunlight Pamela
Anderson visits every now and then he's
[ __ ] man I mean it's it's a terrible
place to be and I don't know if it's
better than prison because it's like the
stress of him never knowing when they're
gonna come knock down the door and pull
him out of there I was like how well
does that guy sleep yeah seven years in
that embassy it can't be great can't be
great gotta be awful they took his
internet away right I think they did
that's front to elbow to be fair
WikiLeaks was releasing information on
specific American soldiers in lines of
combat so were they yes they didn't
redact any of the names that was the
problem that's why people were pissed
really yes Chelsea Manning was that he
dumped all the information to WikiLeaks
including the stuff that was unredacted
and WikiLeaks just released it if you
find differently then let me know
because I'll be happy to correct oh yeah
you know I'm sure you would I just don't
know if it that is I don't know I don't
have the information in front of me do
you want to check no I'll take too much
time
that'll do folks you're gonna have to
google this one but so when one of the
things that I was thinking when Trump
got into office with all this drained
that swamp [ __ ] I was like wonder if
Trump would be a WikiLeaks supporter
I wonder if Trump would be happy depends
but if it helped him yeah sure or even
and Snowden as well about that yeah I
mean it's same sort of thing I mean
unfortunately politics very often has
little to do with principle and
everything to do with convenience yeah
so if it's helpful sure if not god like
him who's
always anti deep state and talking about
the the these extremely critical yes but
once you actually sit in the big seat I
think that tends to change remember
Obama was - yeah then five minutes later
whose drone in people listen I know you
gotta get out of here so let's just wrap
this up tell people about your book yes
you can check out my book the right side
of history talked about a lot of the
sort of deeper issues we were talking
about judeo-christian values and reason
and sort of the it's it's a kind of
short form philosophical history of the
west from Sinai through Greece and
talking about all the major
enlightenment philosophers some of the
things we talked about on the show or in
the book it's number one bestseller on
the New York Times nonfiction list at
least at the moment really pretty
spectacular exciting set your show also
Ben Shapiro show you can get the Ben
Shapiro show on iTunes you can get it on
YouTube
your Sunday review which I did once yeah
it Sunday's special special nice to have
you on again thank you thanks for being
here and your books available on Amazon
everywhere
Ben Shapiro ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Music]